i called to order this second joint
hearing
of the rules and homeland security and
government affairs committees
on examining the january sixth attack
on the united states capital at today's
hearing we will continue our committee's
important work
to get answers that will lead us to
solutions
following the horrific events at this
capital on january 6.
last week we heard from witnesses who
were directly in charge of capital
security
on that day and from local law
enforcement in washington
today we'll hear testimony from the head
of the d.c national guard
and from federal officials from agencies
including fbi
defense department and department of
homeland
security that are tasked with supporting
our security people at the capitol the
testimony of these witnesses is crucial
as we work to get to the bottom of what
happened again
with the focus being on making sure it
doesn't happen again
and with that i know turn it over to
chairman peters for his opinion
statement i will give mine
then senator um blunt
and portman thank you thank you madam
chair
and uh ranking member portman ranking
member blunt and to uh all of our
colleagues from the rules committee for
once again joining us to convene this
second joint hearing on the january 6
attack on our capitol building
last week's hearing provided really the
first
opportunity for the american people to
hear about the
attack directly from the security
officials that were
on the ground today we'll be seeking
answers on the the role of the federal
national security and counter-terrorism
agencies and officials
played in intel intelligence gathering
security planning and response to the
attack
and i want to thank each of our
witnesses for joining us
voluntarily uh here today and i'm
grateful to all of you
and the employees of each of your
agencies including the national guard
units who
continue to assist in protecting the
capital today
we appreciate their continued efforts to
safeguard our national security
and while there are still many
unanswered questions about
january 6 it's clear that this violent
coordinated attack was the result of a
massive and his and historic
intelligence failure
today our committees will once again
examine the
systemic breakdowns that led to this
terrible attack
and particularly how our intelligence
and national security
experts failed to see it coming
this is not a new problem for for years
i've been
raising the alarm about the growing
domestic terrorism threat with the
department of homeland security
the fbi and other key agencies and their
continued failures to adequately and
effectively align
our counterterrorism efforts to address
the threats posed
by domestic extremists but the january 6
attack must mark a turning point there
can be no question that the domestic
terrorist threat including violence
driven by white supremacists and
anti-government groups is the gravest
terrorist threat to our homeland
security moving forward the fbi which is
tasked with leading our counterterrorism
efforts
and the department of homeland security
which ensures that
state and local law enforcement
understands the
threats that american communities face
must address this
deadly threat with the same focus and
resources and
analytical rigor that they apply to
foreign
threats such as isis and al qaeda
today's witnesses are uniquely qualified
to discuss
the intelligence that was produced in
the days leading up to the attack
that officials missed as they assessed
the likelihood of violence
on that day and why our intelligence
community failed to heed the crystal
clear warnings that were broadcast
on social media and publicly reported in
the days leading up to
the six that a violent attack on the
capitol was
likely and imminent we also need answers
about the operational failures that
terrible day especially the response to
the secure the building
once it was breached i'm pleased that we
have representatives of both the
department of defense
civilian leadership and the national
guard
to help us understand why it took
several hours for the national guard to
arrive
and offer additional security and
support
the january 6 attack on the citadel of
our democracy
remains a dark stain on
our nation's history our committee
both of our committees have a
responsibility to carry out our
oversight duties
in a serious and non-partisan way
i look forward to having a productive
discussion and getting the answers that
the american people
deserve and what we need to do to make
sure
that reforms are put in place to prevent
an attack like this from
ever happening again with that i will
turn it back over to
chairwoman klobuchar thank you very much
mr chairman i want to start by thanking
you and ranking member blonde ranking
member portman
for the bipartisan and constructive
hearing that we had last week
i also want to thank the many members of
both committees that patiently
participated during votes and all last
week and asked thoughtful questions that
will help us
move forward importantly there were a
number of areas of agreement
we heard all of our witnesses last week
make clear that there is no evidence
that the insurrection was
deliberate and coordinated uh that it
involved white supremacists
and extremist groups and that it was
highly dangerous but could have been so
much worse
if it was not for the actions of brave
law enforcement on the front line
we also heard consensus from witnesses
who held
key leadership positions in charge of
the capital security now they didn't
agree on everything
but there was consensus there were
breakdowns in
intelligence sharing delays in bringing
in the national guard
and issues concerning the structure of
the capitol police board
and the decision-making process that it
is in our
unique responsibility to change i hope
that the spirit of bipartisanship
and cooperation will continue today as
we hear testimony from federal agencies
on their roles with respect to
intelligence gathering
and timely sharing of intelligence
security preparations
the response and the request for help
from the defense department
as well as their perspectives on how the
capitol police decision making
process could be so much better going
forward
we know that there were errors made by
those in charge
of security in the capital and it is
always easy of course
to realize that later than we're in the
moment
but that fact alone to me isn't enough
to not look back we must look back
because we must do better going forward
we heard last week that the capitol
police is a consumer
that was the word of the former chief of
intelligence it relies on its federal
partners including the fbi
and the department of homeland security
who have witnesses here
today while we are aware of the fbi raw
intelligence report that came out the
day before out of the norfolk
office public reporting has indicated
that neither agency
dhs or fbi produced a threat report that
the fbi did not produce a joint
intelligence bulletin and the dhs
did not produce a threat assessment
ahead of january 6.
and the former police chief has said
that representatives from these agencies
indicated they didn't have any new
intelligence to share
at a meeting before the day of the
attack
but the insurrectionists who attacked
the capital as we know came prepared for
war as we heard last week they brought
radios they brought climbing
gear to surmount the capital security
features
and they brought weapons so we need to
hear from the federal
agencies about what was known and when
what was done
in response to these foreboding online
threats
and how information was shared with the
law enforcement partners
who depend on them we need to also
understand why with all the information
that was available
the decision to reinforce local police
with the national guard
was not made ahead of time now that
decision was made or maybe i should say
rather not
made by the former house and senate
sergeant arms
who in fact have resigned and
nevertheless
despite the clear breakdowns at the
capitol
we must get to the bottom of why that
very day it took the defense department
so long to deploy the national guard
once the need for reinforcements became
patently clear
on every tv screen in america at our
hearing
last week acting chief conte provided a
disturbing account
of how at 2 22 p.m as the rioters
already had broken through police lines
smashed windows at the capitol and were
breaching the building
all on live television the initial
response from the defense department to
a request
of national guard support was not to
immediately activate
the guard as the acting chief said to us
last week
he was quote simply just stunned that
there was not a more immediate response
last an issue of critical importance in
today's hearing is the threat posed by
domestic terrorism and hate groups
and their role in the attack on january
6. we will never
forget the story of the capitol police
officer who fought against the violent
mob for hours
and after it was all over broke down in
tears telling his fellow officers
how he'd been called the n word
repeatedly that day and then
said is this america we also won't
forget the picture
of the insurrectionist proudly waving a
confederate flag in the capital rotunda
or the images of a rioter
in a camp oswitch hoodie but this rising
problem
is not just limited to the events on
january 6.
according to an fbi report hate crimes
in the u.s rose to the highest level
more than a decade in 2019.
putting all the dates and the memos
aside there was
widespread knowledge of the importance
of the date of the rise of violent
extremism
and that the president of the united
states has had called out his followers
to go to the capitol
that day the warnings were dismissed
despite the fact that the vice president
the future vice president
and the entire congress was gathered in
one place
in the end it was left to front line
officers who were severely
outnumbered to protect not only those of
us in the capital
but our democracy itself they performed
heroically under unimaginable
circumstances
tragically suffering many injuries and
loss of life
that's why we need answers thank you
thank you senator klobuchar and senator
peters uh ranked member blunt for
the way you all approach this process um
it's important that we keep it
bipartisan i would even say non-partisan
and i hope that our review continues to
set politics aside
and focus on the facts what happened
that day
and how can we avoid it happening again
i want to begin by expressing again my
gratitude to law enforcement and
national guard is represented here today
from all over the country their national
guard here
and the capitol still and and we
appreciate them we appreciate the fact
that law enforcement put their safety on
the line
to safeguard democracy and also to
protect us and we will never forget that
we owe it to those law enforcement
personnel
and those national guard and to all
americans to take a hard look
at these security failures both the
preparation
it was inadequate clearly and the
response
which also had some gaps we'll talk
about in a moment
how could this have happened that the
capital was breached
and overrun we got some answers last
week at our first joint hearing on the
capitol i agree with what senator
klobuchar just said that it was a
constructive first hearing
i thought it was productive and i
thought we were able to get some
some good information we heard from the
acting
chief of dc metropolitan police the
former chief of capitol police the
former sergeant-at-arms
what was good is that we heard from
people who were actually responsible on
that day
for making decisions i'm concerned that
today we're not going to be hearing from
the department of defense officials who
were actually
in place at the time making the
decisions and i hope we'll have an
option opportunity to do that in the
future
at last week's hearing we learned a
number of things we learned that capital
police officers were not prepared to
respond to an attack like the one we
experienced on january 6 they were not
given the
appropriate training or equipment
necessary to protect
the capital complex but also to protect
themselves
also we learned there were breakdowns in
communication on january 6 and in the
days leading up to it the most
concerning breakdown in communication of
course concerned the
significant discrepancies between the
recollections of the former
chief of capitol police and the former
senate and house sergeant-at-arms about
requests
for backup for national guard assistance
in particular
each testified under oath to a different
version of requests
of events so we'll get to the bottom of
that
the witnesses also pointed to lapses as
intelligence
as a key reason law enforcement was not
better prepared
they all claimed no intelligence warned
of a coordinated violent assault at the
capitol but we know that there were
reports out there both publicly
and from the fbi there was at least one
report from the fbi norfolk field office
warning of a violent attack on the
capitol it was received by u.s capitol
police but never reached
the former chief it never reached the
former sergeant-at-arms
or even the incident commanders on the
ground
many questions remain unanswered despite
the lack of intelligence there were
warning signs
numerous online posts called for
attacking the capital
and the previously mentioned fbi norfolk
field report warned of violence
and even war we need to know what
information the intelligence community
reviewed prior to january 6 how it
assessed that intelligence and how it
characterized the potential for violence
when it shared
that intelligence with law enforcement
second
although last week's witnesses disagreed
about when
the capitol police requested national
guard assistance
all agreed that once requested it took
far too long for the national guard to
arrive
we'll dig further into this today based
on the defense department's public
timeline once requested it took the
national guard
over three hours to arrive at the
capitol
now remember we're all watching this on
on cnn and
fox and msnbc and it's it's it's
it's a riot and yet it took
more than three hours the request came
in from the capitol hill
uh police chief sund at 1 49 p.m
we're told and the capitol hill
deployment did not arrive until after
5 p.m we'll hear some different
timelines on that today but all of them
are
are after 5 00 pm closer to 5 30.
so why did that happen it's unclear when
senior defense officials authorized the
national guard
to deploy the defense department's
public line
public timeline states that army
secretary mccarthy directed the d.c
national guard to mobilize at 304 pm
but according to the timeline the
national guard provided to the
committees and a briefing from major
general walker
commanding general the dc national guard
the instruction to deploy didn't arrive
until 8pm
we know why the gun took so long to
deploy the national guard
according to the former chief of capitol
police and acting
chief of dc police and major general
walker the delay was due in part to
concerns about the
optics of the national guard at the
capitol
we need to know what role if any optics
played in the delay
to provide much needed assistance to u.s
capitol police and d.c metropolitan
police department
to protect the capital and to get people
out of the capital
by hearing from representatives of the
federal agencies responsible for the
intelligence in the national guard
today we expect to get clear answers to
these open questions
answering these questions is critical to
our understanding of where the
breakdowns occurred
on and before january 6 and only by
understanding where the breakdowns
occurred can we make the changes
necessary to ensure
that something like january 6 never
happens again
and that's our objective here with this
oversight
mission again i appreciate the fact that
we've been able to keep the politics out
of this and focus on the facts and and
be objective
we have to continue to do that i look
forward to another constructive hearing
today
thanks to our witnesses for being here i
look forward to your testimony
recognizes uh senator blunt uh for your
ranking member blunt for your opening
comments uh thank you chairman peters
and thanks to chairwoman klobuchar i
joined
my good friend senator portman with my
appreciation for where we've headed with
this so far
and my hope that we continue to look at
the facts and see
where the facts lead us in as much of a
non-partisan way as you can do
in an institution like the united states
senate i'm glad
to join my colleagues for uh today's
hearing to learn more about the
decisions
and the actions of federal agencies on
january the 6th
uh last week's hearing with the chief of
the metropolitan police force the former
chief of the
capitol police and the former sergeants
at arms of the house and senate
really left in many ways with more
questions and answers the witnesses
could not agree
on some of the basics of a timeline
i believe we learned at that hearing
that the structure
and the practice of the capitol police
board which i
previously questioned in fact asked for
a gao study that was issued in 2017
just simply delayed the response and
proved to be ill-suited
for an emergency on the sixth
today i hope to learn if the failure of
capital security leaders were
compounded by officials at the
department of defense who did not act
quickly enough to take the situation
seriously enough i also hope to explore
if the failure to alert the leadership
of the u.s capitol police or the
metropolitan police department
of the fbi's norfolk situation
information report which warned of quote
war in quotes at the capitol
and i understand that that information
was raw and unverified
but should it make us consider changes
in the information sharing process that
we
pursue in this structure
all of the agencies participate in these
hearings
at the most fundamental level exist to
uphold and protect the rights of
americans and to protect our form of
government
january 6 reveal weaknesses in our
intelligence agencies our law
enforcement agencies
and elements of defense agencies it
would be a mistake for the leadership
of those agencies to think it was only a
failure of the u.s capitol police
leadership
or the capitol police board that
produced the terrible result we saw that
day
i look forward to the testimony of our
witnesses and
again thanks for holding this hearing
chairman peters
it's now my uh privilege to introduce
each of the witnesses
that we will be uh hearing from uh here
today and again
uh thank you for your willingness to be
with us
our first witness today is ms melissa
smith slova ms slova is currently the
acting under secretary for the office of
intelligence and analysis at the u.s
department of homeland security
ms slova is the principal advisor to the
secretary of homeland security and the
deputy secretary of homeland security
for coordinating with law enforcement
officials and intelligence to respond to
terrorism and other
threats that the nation faces she
assumed this role on january 20th
2021 prior to that date and on january 6
ms mislova was the deputy under
secretary of the office of intelligence
and analysis
prior to joining dhs she spent almost 20
years in the field of intelligence
analysis which included time
at the defense intelligence agency
welcome
our second witness is miss jill sanborn
since january 2020 ms sanborn has served
as the assistant director
of the fbi's counterterrorism division
where she helps lead the fbi's efforts
to provide information on terrorists
and track down known terrorists
worldwide
ms sanborn first joined the fbi in 1998
and was
assigned to the phoenix field office
prior to becoming assistant
director sanborn served as the special
agent in charge of the minneapolis fbi
field office
was detailed to the ci's
counter-terrorism center
and worked in both the washington and
los angeles
field offices welcome our third witness
is mr
robert say lacey's mr
selecis is currently performing the
duties of assistant secretary of defense
for homeland defense and global security
which he began on january 20th of 2021
prior to this and on january 6 2021 he
was the deputy assistant secretary of
defense for homeland
defense integration and defense support
of civil
authorities in this role mr saleh sees
work closely with federal
state and local leadership law
enforcement
public health and emergency management
to oversee dod's response to
national emergency operations in support
of civil authorities
including the deployment of the national
guard
seriously was appointed to the senior
executive service in 2005
he was awarded the presidential rank
award at the rank of meritorious
executive for his decisive leadership
and program management skills and his
contributions to the national response
plan and the national strategy for
homeland security welcome our final
witness today is major general william
walker
the commanding general of the d.c
national guard
in this role general walker is
responsible for the strategic leadership
training readiness operational
employment and performance
of the army and air force components of
the dc
national guard he reports to the
secretary of the army and is charged
with ensuring units are manned
trained equipped and ready for war and
any
national emergency for the 30 years
general walker served as both a national
guardsman and a special agent of the u.s
drug
enforcement administration a welcome
general
chairman klobuchar those are our
witnesses for today
thank you thank you chairman peters if
the witnesses could now please stand and
raise your right hand
do you swear that the testimony that you
will give before the committee
is the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth so help you god
thank you you can be seated i'll turn it
back over to chairman peters
i think we will uh now begin uh with the
questioning
your statements oh i'm sorry yes i'm
sorry
is celesi i think you are first for your
opening statement
thank you chairman chairman peters
chairwoman
klobuchar ranking members portman and
blunt
distinguished members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
before you today
on the department of defense's support
of civilian law enforcement agencies in
securing the u.s
capitol on january 6 2021.
one of dod's missions is to support
civil authorities
including civilian law enforcement
organizations
dod frequently provides this support
during planned
major events like the presidential
inauguration
and the state of the union addresses due
to the unique nature of the district of
columbia
in which numerous governmental
organizations
exercise a range of jurisdictional
authorities
ensuring safety and security is the
responsibility
of the d.c government the secret service
the park police the marshall service the
capitol police
the federal protective service and other
civilian law enforcement organizations
dod provides support to these civilian
law enforcement agencies
when requested based on their assessment
of the support required
prior to the attack of january 6 dod
worked closely
with federal law enforcement d.c
government partners
to determine if they anticipated a need
for any dod or dc national guard support
related to the planned protests on 31
december the commanding general of d.c
national guard
received a letter from the d.c
government requesting national guard
support
for the d.c metro police at 30 traffic
control points
and six metro stations and to make
available
the dc national guard civil support team
to support the d.c fire and emergency
services over the weekend of january
2nd and 3rd my staff contacted
the secret service the park police the
marshal service
the fbi the capitol police to determine
if they plan
to request dod assistance
none of these organization agencies
indicated a need
for dod or dc national guard support
after consultation with the department
of justice
the acting secretary of defense approved
the d.c government request
for national guard personnel to support
30 traffic control points
and six metro stations from january
5th to the 6th the acting secretary
also authorized a 40-person quick
reaction force
to be readied at joint base andrews
on january 5th the acting secretary of
defense
and the secretary of the army received a
letter
from the mayor of d.c stating mpd is
prepared
and coordinated with its federal
partners namely the park police
the capitol police and the secret
service
based on these communications with
federal and local
civilian authorities dod determined that
no additional military support was
required
on january 5th and 6th
dod has detailed the events of 6
january 2021 in a memorandum published
on defense.gov i will provide
a summary of those key events after the
u.s capitol police
ordered the evacuation of the capitol
complex the secretary of the army
and the commanding general of the d.c
national guard
received calls shortly before 2 p.m
from the mayor of d.c and the capitol
police chief
respectively at approximately 2 30 p.m
the secretary of the army met with the
acting secretary of defense
and other senior leaders of the defense
department
after this meeting the acting secretary
of defense
determined that all available forces of
the d.c national guard
were required to reinforce the d.c
metropolitan police and the u.s capitol
police
and ordered the full mobilization of the
dc national guard
at 304 pm during this period
major general walker the commanding
general at d.c national guard
recalled and made ready the d.c national
guard forces
at the national guard armory for
deployment to the
capital complex after reviewing the dc
national guard's missions equipping and
responsibilities to be performed at the
capitol complex
in support of the metropolitan police
and capitol police
and conferring with the d.c metropolitan
police
at their headquarters at 4 10 p.m
the secretary of the army received the
acting secretary of defense's approval
at 432 and ordered the d.c national
guard forces to deport the armory
for the capital complex dod
continued to deploy national guard
forces through the evening
to support the u.s capitol by nine
o'clock on
seven january eleven hundred national
guard personnel had arrived at the
capitol
by nine o'clock on eight january 1800
national guard personnel had arrived at
the capitol
and by 10 january 6 000 national guard
personnel
were at the capitol providing security
dod continues to support
efforts to protect the safety and
security of the u.s capitol
and provide support to our civilian law
enforcement partners
from january 9 through the inauguration
dod
provided nearly 25 000 national guard
personnel
to support security in washington d.c
today there are approximately 4 900
national guard personnel supporting
capitol police
and 500 supporting the metropolitan
police
going forward the department of defense
is committed
to working closely with our federal
state and local law enforcement partners
the d.c government and the congress
to ensure that we learn from this event
and take all necessary actions to
respond
and ensure an attack on our nation's
capital
never happens again chairman peters
chairwoman klobuchar ranking member
portman and blunt
distinguished members of the committee
thank you for the opportunity to testify
before you today
and thank you for your continued
commitment and support to the men and
women of the department of defense
is smithova you are now recognized
for your opening statement
thank you senator good morning chairman
peters
chairwoman klobuchar ranking member
portman
ranking member blunt and other
distinguished senators
thank you for the opportunity for me to
testify to you
with you today i want to start with
saying i am deeply saddened
by the terrifying events that you your
staff
your loved ones and others experienced
on january
6th the country myself included
watched in horror as our capital was
attacked
i am here today as the acting under
secretary
for the office of intelligence and
analysis ina
at dhs i am a career intelligence
professional
of over 35 years i am honored to have
this opportunity to lead
ina i have great faith in the workforce
and in our mission which is to focus on
on a range of homeland threats including
domestic terrorism
and ensuring that our partners across
state local
private sector have the information they
need
before i summarize the actions my office
took before
january 6 i do want to say i'm deeply
concerned
that despite our best efforts they did
not lead to an operational response to
prepare
and defend the u.s capitol throughout
the 2020 election period
and the presidential transition ina
produced numerous strategic
assessments about the potential for
election-related violence from domestic
violent extremists
in 15 unclassified assessments ina
discussed the heightened threat
environment
and the potential for domestic violent
extremists to mobilize quickly
and attack large gatherings or
government buildings
these products were intended to increase
awareness
about the volatile threat environment
and enhance
both policy and operational planning
they were shared broadly
with all levels of government law
enforcement partners
critical infrastructure including
through fusion centers
nationwide i will highlight a few
products and engagements
in august ina published an assessment on
physical threats
stemming from the 2020 election in which
we assessed
ideologically motivated violent
extremists
and other violent actors could quickly
mobilize
to threaten or engage in violence
against election
or campaign-related targets in response
to perceived
partisan and policy-based grievances
in october dhs released its first
publicly available homeland threat
assessment
which stated racially and ethnically
motivated violent extremists
specifically white supremists would
remain the most persistent
and lethal threat in the homeland
the assessment also emphasized the
breadth of the domestic violent
extremist threat
including the heightened threats from
election-related violence
a week before the attack on december
30th
ina co-authored an intelligence product
with the fbi
and the national counterterrorism center
highlighting persistent threats to
government facilities and law
enforcement
noting the perceptions of the outcome of
the election
could mobilize some extremists to commit
violence
in the coming months additionally
ina proactively conducted briefings and
stakeholder calls
before and after the election and
leading up to january 6
to share that information
moving forward i want to underscore the
department is prioritizing combating
domestic terrorism
specifically in ina we're working very
closely with
our dhs colleagues in the civil rights
civil liberties office
privacy office and our own intelligence
oversight office
to carefully examine how we can better
address the complex and evolving threat
in the manner consistent with the
constitution and u.s law
my office is committed to developing
more expertise
on domestic terrorism improving our
analysis
of social media to better characterize
the threat
and ensuring our assessments are
received and understood
by key decision makers additionally the
department has taken these steps since
january 6.
in late january dhs issued our first
national
terrorism advisory system bulletin on
domestic terrorism
it warned domestic violent extremists
may be emboldened
to act in the wake of the us capital
breach
domestic violent extremists which span a
diverse set of ideological actors
including racially and ethnically
motivated
extremists will continue to exploit
lawful constitutionally protected
protests and other events to pursue
criminal behavior and commit acts of
violence
also for the first time secretary
mayorkas designated domestic violent
extremist
as a national priority area within the
department's
homeland security grant let me say by
let me close by saying my colleagues in
ina and across dhs
are unwavering in our commitment to
ensuring the department is well
positioned
to combat this evolving threat and
protect the american people
thank you for your opportunity to appear
before you today i welcome your
questions
thank you miss sanborn you are now
recognized
for your opening comments
good morning chairwoman klobatar ranking
member blunt
chairman peters ranking member portman
and the members of the committees thank
you for the opportunity to appear before
you today
my name is jill sanborn and i'm the
assistant director for the
counter-terrorism division within the
fbi
it is always an honor to be here with
you in the senate
for those of you that i haven't met or
you don't know i actually started
my career in public service as a senate
page in 1987
thanks to a sponsorship from my home
senator senator max baucus
i want to start by offering my
condolences to all of you
who had to endure up close and
personally
the violence and destruction that
occurred on january 6th
the siege on the capitol complex while
you are carrying out your duties as our
elected representatives
was not just unacceptable and disturbing
it was criminal
i also want to offer condolences to our
partners at u.s capitol police
for the loss of one of their brothers
officer sticknick
this is a loss to us all in law
enforcement
violence designed to intimidate the
population
and influence the government is exactly
what the fbi's counterterrorism division
was designed to combat the men and women
of the fbi are not only dedicated to
identifying and bringing to justice
the individuals involved in the attack
on january 6th
but also and equally as important and
let me stress this
we're committed to working to prevent
something like this from ever happening
again
over the last two months americans the
americans you represent
from across the country have sent in
over two hundred thousand digital media
tips
and reported more than thirty thousand
leads to our national threat operations
center
with this support we have identified
hundreds of people involved in the
attack
and arrested more than 300 with more and
more arrests every day
i want to reiterate something the
director mentioned to some of your
colleagues yesterday
as americans we are all victims of this
assault
and the american people deserve nothing
less than our commitment to see this
investigation through
and to protect them from acts of
violence like this in the future
the fbi's number one priority is
preventing acts of terrorism
the greatest threat we face is the
threat posed by lone actors
both domestic violent extremists and
what we refer to as the homegrown
violent extremists
these actors are especially challenging
for law enforcement because by
definition their insular nature makes
them particularly difficult
to identify and disrupt before they have
an opportunity to act
the fbi has been investigating domestic
terrorism throughout our organization's
history
however today's threat is different than
it was a hundred years ago
and continues to evolve between 2015 and
2020
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists were responsible for the most
lethal domestic terrorism threat and in
fact 2019 was the most lethal
year for domestic domestic violent
extremist attacks
since the oklahoma city bombing in 1995.
however in 2020 three of the four fatal
domestic violent extremist attacks
were perpetrated by what we call
anti-government or anti-authority
violent extremists
one of those attacks was perpetrated by
an anarchist-bound extremist
in portland and in fact this was the
first fatal
anarchist violent extremist attack in
over 20 years
2020 also marked the first year since
2011
that there were no fatal attacks
committed by the racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists advocating
for the superiority of the white race i
think all of those
explain how the threat is persistent and
evolving
looking forward we assess the domestic
violent extremist threat
will continue to pose an elevated threat
of violence to the u.s
we expect racially or ethnically
motivated violent extremists and
anti-government anti-authority violent
extremists will very likely pose the
greatest domestic
terrorism threats throughout 2021
and in fact leading into 2022 regardless
of the specific perpetrator
the domestic terrorism threat remains
persistent and that is why we must
remain focused on countering it
i want to take this opportunity to
re-emphasize that the fbi's mission to
uphold the constitution and protect the
american people
is both dual and simultaneous and not
contradictory
one does not come at the expense of the
other that said when a person crosses
the line from expressing beliefs
to violating federal law and endangers
the communities we serve
we aggressively pursue those threats
before closing i want to mention the
importance of partnerships in the
counter-terrorism fight
we simply cannot be successful without
them our investigations and disruptions
rely
on these partnerships and they represent
american lives
saved in communities around the united
states for instance in fiscal year 2020
alone
your jttfs across the united states
arrested
235 terrorism subjects we also continue
to expand our partnerships in academia
private sector and within the company
communities we serve
this is critical because nearly half of
our cases
are predicated on tips and leads from
the community and our law enforcement
partners
we in law enforcement cannot and will
not tolerate individuals who use the
first amendment as a guise to incite
violence
that's true now as we work hard to hold
those accountable
involved in the events on january 6th
just as it was last summer when
individuals exploited peaceful protests
as cover for their own violence and
destruction
when violent extremists utilize
explosive devices attack government
facilities and businesses
or target law enforcement officers the
fbi investigates those unlawful acts
regardless of the underlying ideological
motivation
at the fb work fbi we work every threat
with the same level of rigor and
dedication
and that's what i hope you take away
from my testimony today
thank you again for an opportunity to
talk with you about the hard work
our folks and our partners are doing
every day to keep the country safe we
are grateful for the support
that you have provided and continue to
provide the men and women of the fbi
i look forward to answering any of the
questions you may have
thank you general walker you are now
recognized
for your opening statement
good morning chairman peters chairwoman
globachar ranking members
portman and blunt and members of the
committees
i am agent general william walker the
commanding general for the district of
columbia national guard
affectionately affectionately known as
capital guardians
i appreciate the opportunity to appear
before you today
to discuss the events of january 6 a
dark chapter in our nation's history
i was personally sickened by the
violence and destruction i witnessed
that fateful day and the physical and
mental harm
that came to u.s capitol police officers
and metropolitan police department
officers
some of whom i met with later that
evening and i could see the injuries
that they sustained
it is my hope that the recollection my
recollection of the events
and my presentation of the facts as i
know them will help your committees
in its investigation and prevent such
tragic events from ever occurring
again first i think it's critical to
understand what the district of columbia
national guard mission was
on january 6 to include the civilian
agency we were supporting
and our request for support of other
civilian authorities were handled
on december 31st 2020 the district of
columbia national guard received written
requests
from the district of columbia mayor
muriel bowser
and her director of homeland security
and emergency management
dr christopher rodriguez the request saw
national guard support for traffic
control and crowd management
for planned demonstrations in the
district from january 5th
through january 6 2021.
after conducting mission analysis to
support the district's request
i sent a letter to the secretary of the
army ryan mccarthy
on january first requesting his approval
i received that approval on a letter
dated
january 5th granting support to the
metropolitan police department
with a 320 guardsmen personnel to
include a 40 personnel quick reaction
force
the district of columbia national guard
provides support to the metropolitan
police department
the united states park police united
states secret service
and other federal and district law
enforcement agencies
in response to planned rallies marches
protests
and other large-scale first amendment
activity on a routine basis
the standard component of such support
is the stand-up of an
off-site quick reaction force an element
of guardsmen held in reserve
with civil disturbance response
equipment helmets
shields batons etc they are postured to
quickly respond to an
urgent and immediate need for assistance
by civil
authorities the secretary of the army's
january
letter to me withheld that authority for
me to employ
a quick reaction force additionally the
secretary of the army's memorandum
to me required that a concept of
operation
be submitted to him before the
employment of a quick reaction
force i found that requirement to be
unusual
as was the requirement to seek approval
to move guardsmen
supporting the metropolitan police
department to move from one traffic
control point to another
at 1 30 p.m on january 6 we watched as
the metropolitan police department began
to employ
officers to support the capitol police
in doing so the officers began to
withdraw
from the traffic control points that
were jointly manned with district of
columbia guardsmen
at 1 49 p.m i received a frantic call
from then chief of united states capitol
police stephen sun
where he informed me that the security
perimeter of the united states capital
had been breached by hostile rioters
chief son his voice cracking with
emotion
indicated that there was a dire
emergency
at the capitol and he requested the
immediate assistance
of as many available national guardsmen
that i could muster
immediately after that 130 149 call
i alerted the u.s army senior leadership
of the request
the approval for chief son's request
would eventually come
from the acting secretary of defense and
be relayed to me
by army senior leaders at 508 pm
about 3 hours and 19 minutes later i had
already had guardsmen on buses at the
armory
ready to move to the capitol
consequently at 5 20 p.m
less than 20 minutes the district of
columbia national guard
arrived at the capitol and were being
sworn in by the united states capitol
police
we helped to establish the security
perimeter at the east side of the
capitol
to facilitate the resumption of the
joint session of congress
in conclusion i am grateful for the
guardsmen from the 53 states
and territories who supported the
district of columbia national guard
operation capital response
and helped to ensure a peaceful
transition of power on january
20th in particular i am grateful for the
timely
assistance from our close neighbors from
virginia delaware and maryland
national guard who augmented d.c
national guard forces
in establishing the security perimeter
i'm honored to lead these citizens
soldiers and airmen
these are your constituents many of whom
left their
left behind their families careers their
education
their businesses to help ensure the
protection and safety of the united
states capital
and those who serve in it every day
thank you for the opportunity to brief
you today and thank you for your
continued support of the national guard
i look forward to any questions you may
have thank you again
thank you general walker thank you for
your testimony and again i know i speak
on behalf of everybody in this joint
committee room that we uh fully support
the men and women of the national guard
and appreciate your work on that day and
continue to appreciate
the service you're providing your
country and protecting the capital as
well as our country so thank you again
general walker i want to start my
questioning by going back in time a
little bit prior to
the events on uh on january 6.
so my question is in june of 2020
as violence was escalating during the
summer protest
were you able to immediately receive
approval
from the secretary of the army and the
secretary of defense
to deploy national guard to assist law
enforcement at that time
senator peters i was yes sir the
secretary of the army
was with me for most of that week he
came to the armory
i was in constant communication with him
when he when we were not
together so you were immediately able to
to uh to receive approval in june of 20.
from your testimony i want to be clear
you were were you
able to immediately receive approval
from the secretary of the army
and the secretary of defense to deploy
the national guard on january
6. no sir in your opening remarks
you said that a january 5th
memo was unusual could you explain to
the committee why
it was unusual and what was the impact
of the memo that you received on january
5th
so the memo was unusual in that i was
it would it required me to seek
authorization
from the secretary of the army and the
secretary
of defense to um
essentially even protect protect my
guardsmen
so no no um civil
civil disturbance equipment could be
authorized
unless it was came from the secretary of
defense now the secretary of the army to
his credit
did tell me that i could have um
force protection equipment with the
guardsmen so
we did have helmets um shin guards
um vest we did have that with us but
that came from the secretary of the army
the secretary of defense
told me i needed his permission to um
escalate to have that kind of protection
that kind of protection even though you
would be engaged in force protection
to protect your your men and women
before you could do that
you would have to get approval from the
secretary of defense
the memo from the secretary of defense
uh made clear that i needed his
permission to to have um so
what it says uh without my uh
personal authorization the district of
columbia national guard does not
authorize the following
to be issued weapons ammunition bayonets
batons or ballistic protection equipment
such as helmets and body armor
now again to to be clear the secretary
of the army told me to go ahead
and issue that equipment so we never
we're going to have weapons or
ammunition
and we no longer have bayonets but we do
have
a ballistic protection equipment helmets
body armor
and um so i did have that with each
guardsman
thank you general so but that was
unusual as you mentioned to have that
kind of request
you you were on the june the january 6
phone call at 2 30 that we heard in from
our previous hearing where the chief of
capitol police was making an
urgent appeal for help
and we heard that the d.c metro police
chief said it was
a tepid response he was shocked by it
what happened on that call what was your
recollection
of the call and where the assessment of
the two individuals i mentioned
was that your assessment as well yes sir
so that that call came in it was uh we
actually helped facilitated the
deputy mayor from the district of
columbia
and dr rodriguez chief conte
uh chief son later joined the
conversation
and we doubt in the senior leadership of
the u.s army
and at that time chief content chief son
passionately pleaded for district of
columbia national guard to
get to the capitol with all deliberate
speed
um so the army senior leaders did not
think that
it looked good it would be a good optic
they further stated
that it could for it could incite the uh
the crowd
so their best military advice would be
to the secretary army who could not get
on the call
so we wanted the secretary of the army
to join the call but he was not
available
we were told that he was with the
secretary of defense and not available
but the army senior leadership expressed
to chief conte chief son dr mitchell the
deputy mayor
and others on the call that it would not
be their best military
advice to have uniformed guardsmen on
the capitol
so so during the call you're saying that
optics was raised
on on that call specifically
so i want to go back to the state the
question i started you said that
uh you were able to get immediate to
authorization
in the summer of 2020 during those
protests
uh general walker was the issue of
optics ever brought up by army
leadership
when the udc national guard was deployed
during the
summer of 2020 was was that discussed
it was never discussed the week of june
it was never discussed july 4th
when we were supporting the city it was
never discussed
august 28th when we supported the city
did you think that was unusual i did
so let's put uh in context you in in in
your opening statements you mentioned
uh the national guard troops that were
ready to go
you had them back at the armory how many
folks
were in the armory ready to go once the
order was given
and at what time were they ready to go
so i
i had them ready to go shortly after the
phone call
so i brought at 1500 i i directed that
the
quick reaction force that was based at
andrews air force base
leave the base get to the armory at all
deliberate speed i had a police escort
bring them to the armory
they they returned to the armory in
about 20 minutes so
we had them sitting there waiting and
then in anticipation
of a green light ago uh we put guardsmen
on buses we brought them inside the
armory so nobody would see
them them uh putting on the equipment
and getting on the buses and then we
just waited
uh to to get the approval and that's why
we were able to get to the capitol in
about 18 minutes
what time were they on the buses ready
to go do you recall
before five o'clock but at five o'clock
i decided hey you know
we gotta there's got to be an approval
coming so get on the buses
get the equipment on get on the buses
and just wait and then a few minutes
after that
we did get the approval i i was on a
secure video conference when the army
leadership conveyed to me
that the secretary of defense had
authorized
uh the employment of the national guard
at the capitol
so my timeline has uh 1708 508 pm
is when um is when we wrote down that we
had approval
and that was about eight people in the
office with me when i got that
oh how many yards when we're ready you
said write immediately earlier in the
afternoon
about 155. so you could have sent 155
much much earlier what would been the
impact of sending those 155
right around that 2 o'clock time frame
well based on my experience
with the summer and i have 19 years i
have 39 years in the national guard
i was in the florida guard hurricane
andrew i've been involved in civil
disturbances
so i believe that number could have made
a difference we could have helped extend
the perimeter
and help push back the crowd
ms sanborn and uh ms uh smithlova
last week we heard from former law
enforcement uh officials who
stated that a lack of intelligence
reporting was the the main reason for
capitol police
not being fully prepared for the january
6 attack
my question to both of you yes or no
would you agree that the intelligence
community failed to
sufficiently identify the threat and
warn the capital police
of a plot to breach the capital that a
plot that was planned
in public and announced in advance
in a number of open sources
i think this is on i'll start i wouldn't
necessarily
categorize it that way sir uh but i will
tell you i think you've heard us say
before there's not an agent that
wouldn't want more tools in their
toolbox
there's not an analyst that wouldn't
want more intelligence and i think i
just paint a quick picture for you the
challenges were faced
are the immense amount of rhetoric out
there and what we're trying to separate
is aspirational from intent
and combine in in order to get to that
intent
we're really thinking about private
communications and oftentimes encryption
and that so i would say that what we are
faced with is the challenge of the
amount of data
and then really trying to find because
of the volume and because of private
communications intent
that then would have given us the
intelligence picture potentially um
to shed light on what some of the plans
and intentions indicators and warnings
as our military folks might say
christmas love
quickly please yes sir uh
i will defer to you senator your
colleagues and other oversight
entities such as this one to actually
determine what went wrong on january 6th
i don't feel i'm empowered or have
enough information
to declare whether or not this is an
intelligence failure
i do know however it was not a success
and we will do
everything we can to make sure that what
we know
is better distributed and understood by
our partners
and to echo the bureau's
point we will also do more to better
understand
how we can identify the next steps that
we see in social media with this
particular threat
well clearly we have to do a much better
job and i'm sure this will be explored
in depth in questioning from my
colleagues here
chairman klobuchar thank you very much
chairman
um i want to start by asking you the
same questions i asked our witnesses
last week and that is that based on what
you know
now including the recent justice
department indictments do you agree
there is clear evidence that supports
the conclusion that
there was those who planned and
coordinated the attack
on the capitol on january 6. does
everyone agree with that
yes no we are seeing indications from
our charging documents of
people that coalesced together before
and made some plans
okay so everyone is a yes on this give
someone
want to say if there are no
i don't want to call on everyone are you
all a yes yes yes ma'am okay
okay um then would you agree that it
involved white supremacists and
extremist groups the planning is
everyone a yes on that
ma'am i just say that we're seeing a
wide range of involvement um
and still a lot left to be identified
right a lot of these no does it involve
white supremacists and
that's what i'm asking sam's famous
group some and was the
uh was the events not planned by antifa
at this point we have not identified a
specific individual that we've charged
associating or self-identifying with
antifa okay thank you
and would you all agree that what
happened was a highly dangerous
situation that had the potential to be
much worse if it wasn't for the heroic
actions of the frontline officers yes
yes thank you all right uh general
walker
i'm gonna start with you i wasn't gonna
start here but i am
after what i just heard um so chief
conte had said that he was stunned at
the response from the department of the
army
uh when former police chief son
requested assistance from the guard
um what's your reaction to what conte
said were you frustrated on that call as
well
yes i was senator global i was i was
frustrated
i was just as stunned as everybody else
on the call
and i understand and correct me if i'm
wrong that with the national guard it is
much better to
um prepare them and call them into
action and have a plan which i know that
i i heard from um mr celestines that
they people tried to do they called the
chief that called people and said you
won't have the guard mobilized
and there was a discussion between you
and son
leading up to january 6 in which this
was discussed and you didn't get a clear
direction
to have them mobilized is that correct
yes ma'am so
so i talked to to chief son on sunday i
talked to him
saturday and sunday we talk we're
friends i've known him for a long time
so on sunday i asked him are you going
to request
dc national guard help and if you do i
need it in writing it has to be formal
because the secretary of defense has to
approve it he told me
he was not allowed to request a support
and i asked him if he wanted me
to share that and he said no
i can't even ask you for the support is
what he told me
but he did say but if i do call you
will you be able to support me i said
yes but i have to get approval from the
secretary of the army
and ultimately the secretary of defense
because it's a federal request
exactly and so as we've heard from chief
son last week
he had been denied by the
sergeant-at-arms and that's
a subject for um last week but the
subject for today
is given all that and we know we would
have been in much better shape if they'd
been called in ahead and if he'd had
authority but now we're to the day and
it is
2 22 and you are on the phone with them
and you're asking um for this
authorization
uh which you felt it was unusual to get
is that right
unusual i thought the delay was unusual
yes and
and so we were already in support of the
metropolitan police department
and when the metropolitan police
department left the traffic control
points
what i wanted to do was take those
guardsmen and move them to the capitol
immediately and my logic was we were
still
in direct support we would have been in
support of the metropolitan police
department
who was supporting the united states
capitol police at that point
so i just keep imagining the scene the
whole country the whole world is seeing
this on tv you've got the police line
breached at this moment
you have you have smashed windows you
have
insurrectionists going through the
police lines you are on the phone
everyone is seeing this on tv and
they're not immediately approving your
request
and in your recent testimony you just
said
hey i could have gotten them on those
buses and ready to go
is that correct that is correct senator
and
as you just testified in response to
senator peters
uh you believe that would have made a
difference to have them at the perimeter
in a sooner point
and i know that the people in charge of
capital security felt the same
yes ma'am and so you could have had them
there earlier hours earlier if it had
been
approved and um then you had them on the
bus
and so they were actually sitting on the
bus for a short period of time right
waiting because you thought well they've
just got to honor the request is that
how your head was working so you
actually
put them on the bus so they were ready
to go but you couldn't let the buses go
yes senator i i just came to the
conclusion that
that eventually i'm going to get
approval and i didn't want
and i at that point seconds mattered
minutes mattered
and i needed to be ready to get them
there as quick as possible so i already
had
district of columbia national guard
military police vehicle in front of the
bus
to help uh get through any traffic
lights so we were there in 18 minutes
i i arrived at 17 20. okay
yeah and they were sworn in as soon as
they got there and they made a
difference
according to the capitol police well
according to a lot of us
and i i just keep thinking of the hours
that went by
and the people who were injured and
the officers whose lives were changed
forever
a lot has been reported about the quick
response force that was waiting at
andrews air force base to be
deployed to d.c just in case now that
force was set up
uh as additional troops to support the
guards traffic control
uh mission is needed is that right yes
ma'am
and the quick response force couldn't be
deployed to the capitol immediately once
the violence began because they were
not outfitted for riot control is that
right
no ma'am they were outfitted so so the
quick reaction force was
district of columbia air national guard
security forces squadron
most of those guardsmen are law
enforcement officers and their civilian
positions got it so so they were pro
they were ready to go and they were
outfitted with all the equipment that
they needed and they were out at andrews
they were that andrews
and i just took it upon myself to move
them
without permission i just moved them to
the armory so they would be closer as
well
okay she was on the conversation with
you
um you mentioned from the from the
defense department
i know who that was on there from the
police in
d.c so lieutenant general michael flynn
he was the chief he was in charge of
operations for the army
the director of the army staff was on
the phone was on the call lieutenant
general piet
there were other senior civilian leaders
from the united states army
and other high-ranking general officers
were on the call as well
okay and do you remember who was mostly
talking about the optics the questions
that senator peters asked you and their
concern about that
yes so during the phone call with uh
with the district of columbia
national the district of columbia uh
leaders
the deputy mayor chief son dr rodriguez
who was talking about optics were
general flynn
and general piatt and and they both said
it wouldn't be in their best military
advice to
advise the secretary of the army to have
uniformed guards members
at the capitol during the election
confirmation
thank you mr
celaeus could you explain
why they would say such a thing i know
you were not on the call and
you were the one that they sent here on
behalf of the defense department but you
were
not on the call and so do you have any
idea why this delay occurred
uh when as uh senator peters has
pointed out it didn't occur in other
incidences
uh senator as you point out i was not on
the calls
any of the calls we know that that's why
i spent my time talking to someone who
was
right however senator in preparation for
the hearing
i have had the opportunity to talk to
general walker i've had the opportunity
to talk to general piatt and other
general officers on the army staff
i've also had the opportunity to talk to
secretary mccarthy
in preparation for the hearing so that i
could understand the details
okay so just if you could answer my
questions there's so many my colleagues
waiting
um why this happened general piatt told
me
yesterday that he didn't say anything
about optics
he maybe he meant he didn't use the word
optics are you saying that general
walker who just testified that they were
concerned about this is wrong
or that general pilate told me yesterday
senator
that he did not use the word optics i
think that what i'll let general walker
answer this but i think what he's
talking about is the general concern of
that
um was that they were more concerned
about how this would appear and it was
in their best advice and i guess
what bears out his testimony is that
they did not
send the national guard there for hours
they didn't give the authorization for
him as he waited with his troops
to go over to the capitol senator and
and fairness to the committee
general pie is not a decision maker the
only decision makers
on the 6th of january were the secretary
of defense
and the secretary of the army ryan
mccarthy it was a chain of command
from the secretary of defense to
secretary mccarthy to general walker
that was the chain of command
there's lots of staff that was involved
in obviously having discussions
but to be clear on that day that was the
chain of command
just could i give general walker i think
we should give him a moment to respond
here and then i'll be done
yes senator so so the chain of command
is the president the secretary of
defense secretary of the army
william walker commanding general
district of columbia national guard can
i can i just make a correction
i said lieutenant general um
mike flynn it was lieutenant general
charles flynn got it
i'm sorry sorry i just wanted to correct
that okay but uh but there were people
in the room with me
on that call that heard what they heard
okay we'll have to follow up with more
questions i appreciate your testimony
thank you
thank you member portman you're
recognized for your questions
thank you uh chairman peters and thanks
to our witnesses
uh general walker can continue to talk
about your recollection if you don't
mind
this morning you have testified that you
received this letter from my secretary
mccarthy
on january 5th so just the day before
the attack on the capitol
in that letter did secretary mccarthy
prohibit you from employing the national
guard's quick reaction force without his
authorization
so i have the letter in front of me and
his letter
does not but it is the secretary of
defense
says that i have to use it as a last
resort
but the secretary of the army told me
and it's um
i have the letter that i could not use
the
quick reaction force it would it would
he would
i would just read it yeah i would hold
authority to approve employment of the
district of columbia national guard
quick reaction force
and will do so only as a last resort in
response to a request from an
appropriate
civil authority i will require a concept
of operation
prior to authorizing employment of a
civil
of a quick reaction force now a quick
reaction force normally is a commander's
tool
to go help either a civilian agency
but more typically to help the national
guardsmen
who are out there and need need
assistance
yeah i think it's a very definition of a
quick reaction force to be able to react
quickly
and you've got to go through that kind
of an authorization including coming up
with a
concept of operation before the
secretary
or as you say
the secretary of defense so the
secretary of army secretary of defense
would approve
deployment uh seems to me to be contrary
to the whole concept of
of a quick reaction force
um and just to be clear the secretary of
defense
said i could use it as a last resort
last resort right but the secretary army
says that i could only use it after
he gave me permission and only then
after
a concept of operation and we talked
about the chain of command earlier so
your chain of command is both of these
gentlemen in other words you you didn't
have the authority to deploy that quick
reaction force
based on either the letter or the
earlier memo that went from the
secretary
of defense acting secretary of defense
to the secretary of the army
is that that's correct yes sir um
yeah i also thought it was odd and i
think you said it was unusual
and very prescriptive that the january
5th letter required
the secretary of the army to approve the
movement of deployed guardsmen from one
traffic control point to another
did you find that unusual 19 years i
never
i never had that before happen so on
that day
the metropolitan police as they would
any other day
requested that a traffic control point
move
one block one block over traffic was
no traffic was where they were so they
wanted the the traffic control point to
move one block
i had to get permission i told him i'll
get back to you
i contacted lieutenant general piatt who
contacted the secretary of the army
we i had to explain where that traffic
control point was
in relationship to the capital and only
then did i get permission
to move the the three national guardsmen
supporting the metropolitan these are
three
unarmed national guardsmen who are
helping with traffic control in part so
that metfalton police can do other
things and they were not permitted to
move a block
uh away without getting permission from
the secretary of the army is that true
that's correct yeah and then on your
testimony you also
talk about riot gear
that january 4th memorandum from acting
secretary miller uh to the army
secretary required the personal approval
of the secretary of defense for the
national guard to be issued riot gear is
that correct
that's correct but but the secretary
army told me to go ahead
and put it in the vehicles yeah so i'll
give him credit for that
yeah and you said that earlier you gave
him credit for saying at least to have
it there
so it was uh accessible yes but still
you couldn't
prepare for a civil diso disturbance um
without getting permission from the
secretary
of the army and the secretary of defense
is that true normally for
a safety and force protection matter
a commander would would be able to
authorize
his guardsmen to protect themselves with
with helmet
and and protective equipment well as i
said earlier i'm disappointed we don't
have someone from dod who actually was
there
at the time i think you're being put
into a deaf position mr
thales but mr sales says i have to ask
you why did the department of defense
impose these restrictions on general
walker's control of the national guard
on january 6.
um secretary miller wanted to make the
decisions
of how the national guard was going to
be employed on that day
as you recall senator the uh spring
events
there was a number of things that
happened during those events
that uh secretary miller as as the
acting secretary
yeah well clearly clearly he he wanted
to the question is is why
and and how unusual don't you think
that's unusual based on your experience
at d.o.d
senator there was a lot of things that
happened in the spring but don't
know what you think i was criticized for
uh sir if i if i could senator
uh civil disturbance operations that
authority
rests with the secretary of defense so
if if somebody is going to make a
decision about employing military
members
against u.s citizens in a civil
disturbance operation
let's talk about the quick reaction
force then again you've got a lot of
experience
looked at your background we appreciate
your being here again you weren't making
any decisions that day uh then kind of
put you forward here as the person to
answer questions
but uh based on your discussions with
with
individuals uh but isn't the purpose of
a quick reaction force to quickly react
to unfolding situations
senator it is it is disaster isn't
requiring a pre-submitted concept of
operations antithetical to the idea of
enabling
quick reaction again senator i i would
call our attention to the quick reaction
force that day
was designed to respond to the traffic
control points in the metro stations
we did not have a quick reaction force
to respond
to the events that unfolded on the
capitol well i don't know that that's
true
general walker did you not have a quick
reaction force as part of the d.c please
i think you did you had
police officers who were also guardsmen
who were involved in your quick reaction
force correct
i did and wouldn't they have been
appropriate to respond to the attack on
the capitol
in my opinion they would have been um i
i don't know look i
again i i i wish we had the people who
were making the decision
uh mr salasis and i i don't want to put
you
in this position but you're all we've
got in terms of talking to dod today um
in your opinion did the attack on the
capitol constitute a last resort
last resort you mean an immediate
response sir i know in
in the remember in the in the letter it
said only as a last resort
do you think a last resort situation
occurred when there was an attack on the
capitol
there was certainly a last resort
situation that occurs
so why did it take the department of
defense so long to authorize the use
of the national guard in particular
the use of the um of the
of the qfr senator i can relay
what i've obtained from my discussions
with the personnel that were involved
that day
and uh if if you'd like to go through
the timeline you just answered the
question
based on why uh the decision makers in
this case secretary mccarthy
secretary mccarthy uh if we go through
the timeline
clearly at 222 has been mentioned today
uh secretary mccarthy at 2 30 as i
pointed out my oral statement
went down and sourced secretary miller
at 2 30.
at 2 at 304 secretary miller made the
decision
to mobilize the entire national guard
that meant that
he was calling in all the national guard
members that were assigned to the dc
national
guard at 3 40 304 that decision was made
between that period of time between 304
and 410 basically secretary mccarthy had
asked for
he wanted to understand because of the
dynamics on the
on the capitol lawn with the explosives
that
uh obviously shots had been fired he
wanted to understand the employment
of how the national guard was going to
be sent to the capitol
what their missions were going to be
were they going to be clearing buildings
would they be doing perimeter security
how would they be equipped he wanted to
understand how they were going to be
armed because obviously
shots had been fired he was asking a lot
of questions to understand exactly how
they were going to be
employed here at the capitol and how
many national guard members needed to be
employed on the capitol let me just say
with all due respect and my time is
coming to an end you know three hours
and 19 minutes three hours and 19
minutes from the first
call plea really with his voice cracking
with emotion as
the major general said you have
chief of police son saying help we need
help
now three hours and 19 minutes and that
can't happen again
do you agree with that senator i do
thank you
very good ranking member blunt
thank you chairwoman um general walker
if the restrictions on your authorities
hadn't been put in place by dod
what would you have done when chief son
called you at
149 on january 6 with an urgent
request for national guard assistance
i would have immediately pulled all the
guardsmen that were supporting the
metropolitan police department they had
the gear in the vehicles
i would have had them assemble in the
armory
and then get on buses and go straight to
the armory and report to the
the most ranking capital police officer
they saw
and take direction and and furth
just let me add this so one of my
lieutenant colonels on his own
initiative went to the capitol
anticipating that we were going to be
called so he would have been there
and he met with deputy chief carol of
the metropolitan police department who
asked him
where is the national guard how come
they're not here
and this colonel said well i'm sure
they're coming
and i'm here to scout out where they're
going to be when they get here
so that was the plan i would have sent
them there immediately
as soon as i hung up my next call would
have been to my subordinate
commanders get every single guardsman in
this building
and everybody that's helping the
metropolitan police
remission them to the capitol without
delay
and how quickly do you think you could
have had people here i think you said a
minute ago that the
the guard had moved from andrews to
the armory here by 3 30 is that right
yes sir
and how quickly was the colonel here
that was uh
he came with the police so so he was
here immediately
yes sir yes sir he was here immediately
when the metropolitan police
left some of the traffic control points
my colonel left with them and came
straight to the capitol anticipating
that
that's where the fire was and that fire
needed to be put out well i
there certainly was concerned here
immediately in fact yesterday i saw
a message that i sent mr elder who was
the
director of the rules committee for me
when i was chairman at the time and the
quote on that message that text message
was
could this information about the defense
department and the national guard
possibly be true that's 309
already wondering where senator
klobuchar and i and other senators were
could it possibly be true that the
defense department
was not sending the guard
immediately uh mr salasis um
on the january fifth letter
that that's described as secretary
mccarthy
relaying new restrictions from the
acting secretary of the defense
miller christopher miller would would
that be accurate would those be
new instructions and do you agree that
general walker had more flexibility
before those
instructions than he did after i think
that's a yes or no
do you agree he had more flexibility
before those instructions than he did
after that would be one question
and two would it be fair to say those
were new instructions or
not sir senator uh
general walker in fairness to him can't
respond to a civil defense
a civil disturbance operation without
the authority of the secretary of
defense
so absent these memos
general walker would have had to get
approval to respond to the capital
through the secretary of defense well
let's talk about that approval process i
i think you said a minute ago to senator
portman
if you'd like to go through the timeline
i assume you're talking about the
department of defense
timeline that i have in front of me you
mentioned
1504 as one of your reference points
at 1519 or 319
that timeline says the secretary of the
army
phone call with senator schumer and
speaker pelosi about the nature
of mayor bowser's request
secretary of the army explains acting
secretary defense
already approved full dc
ng full dc national guard mobilization
would that be
right as of 319 that would be accurate
but
if i could clarify what mobilization let
me let me go one step further and i'll
let you do that at
15 26 326
secretary of the army phone call with
mayor bowser and
metropolitan police chief relays that
there is no denial of their request
and conveys assistant secretary or
acting secretary defense
approval of the activation
of full national guard so on your
timeline within seven minutes
one is mobilization the other is
activation
go ahead and explain what those two
things mean so
senator those words are being used
interchangeably what what secretary
miller did
at 1504 on 6 january
was authorized the mobilization or
activation of the national guard
the dc national guard all that does sir
is provide
for the national guard to be called in
from
wherever their homes are to come to the
armory that's what the mobilization
activation order was
i wonder if that's what um secretary um
i don't know if that's what senator
schumer and speaker pelosi thought it
meant now you can't answer that only
they could
and i also wonder if that's what mayor
bowser thought it meant
when they were told at 3 19 and 326
that the guard was being mobilized and
the guard was being
activated i i don't expect you to be
able to answer
what they thought i know i would have
assumed
that that meant the guard was on the way
unless i was specifically told
well they're mobilized but they really
won't be there until we make a decision
hours later at 4 32
the acting secretary of defense provides
verbal authorization
to remission d.c national guard to
conduct perimeter and clearance
operations
so that's 4 32 that's an hour and
ten or so minutes later is that the
moment when
the guard was told they could move
forward yes senator it is
do you agree with that general walker no
sir
so i didn't get approval until a little
bit after five
and i got that from the secretary army
who was relayed to me
i never talked to secretary of defense
miller
um and i didn't talk to the secretary of
the army army senior leaders told me at
about 1708
508 pm that the secretary of defense
has authorized our approval to support
the capital
the senator if if i could in fairness to
general walker too
that's when the secretary of defense
made the decision
at 4 32 as general walker has pointed
out because i've seen all the timelines
he was not told that until 508. that's
what
how's that possible mr salazar do you
think that the decision
in the moment we were in was made at 432
and the person that had to be told
wasn't told
for more than half an hour after the
decision was made
senator i think that's that's an issue
there was decisions that were being made
there was communications that needed to
take place and then there was actions
that had to be taken
all of that was happening
at simultaneous times by different
individuals
and i think that part of the challenge
is that
some of the delayed communications
probably
put some of the challenges that we had
that day well i would think so if you
have to have the communication before
general walker and the national guard
can take the action
and the communication doesn't require
for doesn't occur
for over half an hour that's uh that's a
significant
problem uh for the future if we don't
figure out how the decision
the the communication and the action
all happen as nearly to the same time as
they possibly can
thank you very much uh senator hassan
well thank you very much uh chair
chairwoman
klobuchar and chair peters and our
ranking members
blunt and portman uh for this hearing
and i want to thank all of our witnesses
for being here today and i want to thank
you all for your service to our country
i want to start with a question
for ms mislova please
it's about a topic that i asked about
last week the secretary of homeland
security has the authority
to designate events with national
significance as national special
security events
and these designated events receive
expanded federal
support for event security factors used
to determine national special security
event designations include the
attendance of u.s officials
as well as the size and significance of
the event
in our hearing last week the former
officials in charge of security here at
the capitol
testified that dhs did not reach out to
u.s capitol officials
about designated january 6th joint
session of congress
as a national special security event so
ms
ms mislova to your knowledge did any
department of homeland security
officials
ever consider or recommend designating
the january 6 joint session of congress
as a national special security event
sorry thank you senator uh
no to my knowledge no one at the
department of homeland security
did consider designating january 6
as an nssc also to my knowledge
no one responsible for protecting the
capital asked for such a designation
right but but when it when we're talking
about an ns
nsse uh we you don't need a request
from the capital class you could have
dhs could have initiated it
so what is the department's current
policy and process
for designating national special
security events
and were there any procedural issues
blocking such a designation
in spite of the growing evidence of
intelligence available to federal
security officials prior to the event
i'm sorry senator i am running currently
the office of intelligence and analysis
for dhs
we have a small role in the nssc process
but i am not qualified to speak about
the whole process it's fairly
complicated
i'm happy to have secret service
reach out to you ma'am if if you'd like
me to follow up with that
well i i think it's really important for
us to understand what the processes are
we had as has been pointed out the vice
president
the vice president-elect all members of
congress
in one location at an event where there
was clear
uh intelligence that might turn violent
and
there appears to have been no uh
communication or effort by dhs to
designate this in a way that would have
uh had this security that we're now
standing about stood up
ahead of time in an effective way so i
look forward to following up with you on
that
uh i want to turn to ms sanborn now
according to a recent report the fbi has
currently charged 257 people
associated with the events on january 6.
of the individuals charged to date
in relation to the attacks of january 6
how many were already under
investigation by the bureau
ma'am i'd have to get you the specific
number but i can only recall from my
memory
one of the individuals that was under
investigation
prior and was that because the fbi is
limited
in its tools or capacity to
monitor charge or arrest these
individuals prior to january 6.
it was this a manpower issue i'm just
trying to understand
understanding looking back now what
might have made a difference
in charging and being able to move
against some of those individuals sooner
yeah i think that's a great question i
think it's twofold so it's the
complexity of trying to gather the right
intelligence that helps us predict
indicators and warnings and i spoke
earlier about
while there's a volume out there of
rhetoric trying to figure out that
intent is very challenging for us in the
intel community because it happens on
private comms and encryption so that's
one aspect
and then the other aspect is of the
people that we were investigating so
predicated investigative
investigations we don't necessarily have
the ability to
mitigate the threat they might pose by
travel if we don't have a charge and so
i think you're tracking that we were
aware of some of our subjects that
intended to come here
we took over action by going and talking
them and trying to get them to not come
and that worked in the majority of our
already predicated cases
okay thank you i'd look forward to
following up with the fbi more about
that
uh i also have another question for you
about the fbi's information sharing
practices
on january 5th the fbi norfolk field
office issued a report that some
extremists were preparing to travel to
washington
and commit acts of violence that report
eventually made it to a u.s capitol
police analyst
but it didn't make it to the former
capitol police chief
mr sund so i think it's important for us
to understand whether this was a failure
in information sharing policy or
practice
what's the standard policy for
disseminating reports like that
yes ma'am that's a great question i'd
just like to segue into that that
part of the reason we were able to get
that intelligence report from the
norfolk office is because we made it a
national
collection priority for all 56 field
offices to collect
whatever they could on the joint session
as well as inauguration
and so when they collected that
information they did follow our normal
process and i think we heard yesterday
from the director and went above and
beyond that process so they documented
it
quickly within the situational
information report
and they disseminated it three different
ways in writing
via email verbally and then also put it
in what we call the leap portal which is
available to all state and local
partners across the united states
so i'm trying to understand though how
it didn't get
elevated or communicated to the highest
level who was the highest official in
the fbi to be informed of the
intelligence
so i similar to director ray found out
about it days after
and so i think it's very important to
also caveat what that was
it was raw unvetted information and only
because of the collection message did it
get as quickly elevated to the
washington field office
and disseminated to the task force
officers so
thousands and thousands of tips come in
just like this on every day and not all
of those get elevated to senior
leadership
except that this was tips about violence
the united states capitol where we were
going to have all members of congress
the current vice president the vice
president-elect and
so given the gravity of the threat it is
very hard
for me to understand why somebody didn't
pick up
the phone and i'd like to understand too
whether
any of the following were informed of
the intelligence the president
the white house chief of staff the
attorney general of the united states
the speaker of the house of the senate
majority leader
not to my knowledge ma'am and i think
you heard the director say this
yesterday and i echo at 100
anytime an attack happens we're going
back and we're going to figure out what
we could have done better and
differently so i echo your
there's always processes that can be
improved look i will just say this
that one of the things before a major
event that one should always do
is figure out who the leadership is and
they should be talking twice a day on
the phone for the week leading up at
least
that's kind of standard practice at
least in the states that i'm familiar
with it's certainly standard practice
uh for governors and it is astounding to
me
that even if it's raw intelligence uh
given what the stakes were on january 6
that that kind of sharing wasn't routine
and that it didn't happen
so i i hope very much that we'll we will
look back at this and develop
kind of standard operating procedures so
that uh the leadership of security at
the capitol the leadership
of security and all the various agencies
are sharing this kind of information
person to person rather than relying on
standard
um emails and the like thank you very
much i will say that's the purpose of
the command post and but
100 echo your point which is let's go
back and figure out what we could do
differently
okay thank you thank you man thank you
thank you senator hassan and for a
member of the rules committee we are
following the
order uh set forth by the homeland
security committee how they do their
order so if there's questions about that
that's how we're doing it today and next
is senator feinstein
thanks very much madam chairman
um i'd like to ask this question
in august of 2017
dhs office of intel and analysis
and the first virginia fusion center
issued a report
days before the violent protests in
charlottesville
virginia the report warned that the
protests could be among the most
violent today it warned that anarchist
extremists and white supremacist
exterm extremists are calling on
supporters to be prepared for
and to instigate violence at the 12
august rally
now this was very similar to what we saw
in the lead-up
to the january 6 insurrection when
groups were actively planning to come to
washington
and commit violence yet there was no
similar intelligence report by the
department of homeland security
for this occasion my question is
why and what happened to change
this procedure yes senator
uh thank you for that question um
between before the election
and then into the inauguration
ina did publish 15 separate unclassified
reports
that did discuss specifically that there
was a heightened threat environment
that the threat could come from lone
actors or small cells
we assessed that those that were
motivated
by concerns about the election
and grievances associated largely with
covid 19 restrictions
would also appear to be armed and we
also warned that they could transition
quickly from a peacetime situation
into a violent situation i
actually in preparation for this hearing
did review all of those reports
and was impressed with how well the team
did they were very well written
and very specific the point senator is
that we thought we had provided that
warning
we did not have anything specific about
an attack on the capital to occur on
january
6th so we did not issue a separate
report
in hindsight we probably should have but
we had just issued a report
on december 30th with our colleagues at
fbi
and the national counterterrorism center
when we had thought
ma'am that that was sufficient i'd like
to ask that you make those reports
available to this committee
happy to please
also press reports indicate that acting
defense secretary christopher miller
issued a memo on january 4th preventing
the d.c
national guard from receiving weapons or
protective gear interacting with
protesters
or employing riot control agents without
his personal
authorization do you know of any other
instance
where a defense secretary required
personal
authorization before allowing national
guard troops
to respond to an emergency
and i'd like to put the letter from
christopher miller
madam chairman in the file if i could
yes
without objection could someone answer
that
i'm sorry senator i'll answer that
question i was waiting um
senator i'm i'm not aware of another
letter from a secretary
but again based on events in the spring
and secretary miller
being new to the department at that time
and some of the things mindful that
happened
he issued that direction that direction
though again i'd come back to the point
that
in order for national guard members to
deploy in civil
disturbance operations it requires the
secretary of defense's approval
so just as to be clear there's the
there is no ability for the military to
respond
without the secretary's approval for
civil disturbance operations
well if i may madam chairman i'm looking
at a memo for secretary of the army
employment guidance for the district of
columbia national guard
dated january 4 2021 i received it
um and it responds to a memorandum
regarding the district's request
for support for the planned
demonstrations from january 5th
to 6th 2021
and you are authorized to approve the
requested support
subject to my guidance below subject to
consultation
and um then it points out a number of
things that are not
authorized so this letter
of january 4 i'd like to be in the
record
because um
somewhere there's a problem here and
i've been listening carefully trying to
find out
what the problem is but
there were certain reports that just
were not issued
and they were of an intelligence nature
and uh i'm curious about finding out
which ones
essentially did what so if you have any
response to that
other reports um and could let this
committee know
it would be appreciated
yes ma'am happy to do so we i think the
key here is and i think
my dhs colleague mentioned this is the
intelligence we had
articulated that we knew people were
coming to the dc area
we knew there was a possibility they
would come armed and potentially
have conflict amongst themselves what we
lacked and i think you heard this last
week from all the folks that testified
as well
none of us had any intelligence that
suggested individuals were going to
storm and breach the capital and that
was the intelligence
that we lacked
well i think that remains to be seen but
i appreciate the comment
and i think that's what this committee
has to look for
and make a determination whether there
was in fact
adequate pre-question
pre-interest and there is a record
and i thank you madam chairman thank you
senator johnson you're recognized for
your questions thank you mr chairman
uh before i get into my line of
questioning for today's subject
uh miss solis i know miss uh
smizlova uh i received when i
was sitting here in the hearing a press
release from
capitol police that said that we have
obtained intelligence that shows a
possible plot to breach the capital by
by an identified militia group on
thursday march
4th is that a threat that you're aware
of
uh senator we i issued a bulletin
last night uh co-authored with the fbi
about uh extremists discussing
discussing march 4th
and march 6. is that is that what you're
referring to it's a joint intelligence
bulletin
we released last night around it was
very late midnight i think
yes okay well again so the threats are
ongoing
yes general walker to review the
timeline
at 1 49
chief sund contacted you
at 2 15 the capital was breached
i think in your testimony you said you
had uh available
340 dc national guard troops is that
correct
well sir it was actually half of that so
so half were
on the streets helping the metropolitan
police department
the other half would have came in to
relieve them but but we would have
called them in to come in okay
so you had 40 in the quick quick
reaction force correct yes sir so had
you been able to
you know had this all been pre-approved
by the secretary of defense
and i'm mindful of of the considerations
of having
military involved in civil disturbances
i think that's part of the issue
uh some of the blowback that occurred
with the with the spring
instances how quickly could have you
gotten
how many people to the capitol 20
minutes
how many people 150
okay i think that's important
information to have
um i think quite honestly what we need
to do here is we need to completely
reconstruct
what happened and i mean completely
reconstructed
we need to obtain eyewitness testimony
from different vantage points from
different
perspectives and that's certainly what
i've tried to do uh
miss sanborn how many points of
confrontation
occurred during the riot
i mean in other words were these
primarily at choke points
doors windows that were breached and
then inside the capitol again
uh outside the house chamber or was
there a you know the capital's 751 feet
long was this a 751 long
line that's that the capitol police and
other law enforcement
were battling protesters
uh thank you for the question i think
we're still in the process of gathering
that data
obviously the folks that we have charged
we've charged for breaching and getting
inside and so we at least know that at
some point they got through a choke
point
the actual distance of how long that was
is still part of what we're examining
sir
okay but you're we've got all kinds of
video
all kinds of photographs so you
obviously are examining that
and from that video you've been able to
arrest
300 people 300 people have been charged
18 have been charged with conspiracy 40
men or
40 have been arrested for assault
a law enforcement officer so have you
looking at those
videos maybe not being able to identify
the people but have you counted
the number of people that you want to
identify for example
that will probably be charged with
assault so we're still doing that um and
that number increases just like the
arrests every day and so far we have
identified hundreds of people that we're
trying to still identify
okay we'll again we've got 300
individuals have been charged
40 you've been charged by assault do you
expect the
hundreds of people to be charged with
assault or will those be
disorderly contact unlawful entry i mean
what
give me some sort of sense of the the
extent of this
absolutely it's a fair question so i
think the charges have ranged from
everything from trespassing
to obstruction to definitely assault on
federal officers we have a fair number
of those and so the
charges based on the actual behavior
that the individual part took that day
definitely vary how many firearms were
confiscated
uh in the capitol or on capitol grounds
during that day
to my knowledge we have not recovered
any on that day from any other arrests
at the scene at this point but
i don't want to speak on behalf of metro
and capitol police but to my knowledge
none so
nobody's been charged with an actual
firearm weapon
in the capitol or on capitol grounds
correct the closest we came was the
vehicle that had the molotov cocktails
in it and when we did a search of that
vehicle later on there was a weapon but
how many shots were fire that we know of
i believe the only shots that were fired
were the ones that resulted in the death
of the
um one lady okay well again i appreciate
the the chairs comments about uh
a bipartisan nonpartisan investigation
here seeking out the truth that's what
i'm trying to do
uh cognizant of how it was i was reacted
to
by offering an eyewitness account at the
last year i'll
risk entering another piece of uh
reporting into the record this is from
the new york times hopefully that'll be
viewed more favorably the title is a
small group of militants
outsized role in the capital attack in
that report
it says federal prosecutors have said
members of the oath keepers militia
group
planned and organized their attack and
quote
put into motion the violence that
overwhelmed the capital the reason i'm
entered this in the record and read that
quote is it it really does seem to align
with the eyewitness account that i
uh read parts portions of the record
last week
no conspiracy theory just an eyewitness
account from a knowledgeable observer
i didn't get to the point of the actual
attack and i want to just read a couple
excerpts
this is the title provocateurs turn
unsuspecting marches into an invading
mob
and again these provocateurs are
primarily white supremacist
groups then allowed bellowing shout from
behind quote forward do not retreat
forward
then two other men standing across from
one another on the high granite curbs on
either side of the footpath belt
variations of
forward do not dare retreat some made
direct eye contact to people and pouring
directly at them as if trying to psych
them into
submitting a third man standing on a
chair also shouting forward reached
reached down and grabbed me by the
shoulder and barked
don't retreat get back up there it
wasn't an expression of enthusiasm
or solidarity it sounded like a military
order and it wasn't from from a
wild-eyed kid
this guy was probably in his 50s he
looked furious with me
nobody nobody seemed to wear the capital
was physically under attack
the tear gas caused pandemonium but
there was still no stampede and people
helped create or widen paths to allow
others to leave the area
then from the north a column of
uniformed agile younger men walked
briskly
single filed toward the inaugural stand
they came from they came within two feet
of me their camouflage uniforms were
clean neat and with a pattern i couldn't
identify these were the disciplined
uniform column of tactors i had seen
there were a good three dozen of them
moving in a single snake-like formation
they were organized they were
disciplined they were prepared we're
taking the capital the first or second
announced
you're going to get arrested someone
called ms sanborn is that kind of
does that tie into with what you're
uncovering as you investigate
exactly what happened in campbell that
day that you had these
armed militia groups that had conspired
and organized to be there
maybe dozens we don't know how many but
that they
were organized and knew how to use the
mob
to storm the capital is that kind of
what you're seeing we definitely so far
are seeing a mixture that absolutely
we're seeing people that got caught up
in the moment got caught up in the
in sort of the energy etc um and made
their way into the capital and those are
probably the ones that you're seeing the
charges simply of trespassing and then
we're definitely seeing that portion
that you're pointing out which is
small groups and cells now being charged
with conspiracy
that coalesced either on site or even
days or weeks prior
and had sort of an intent that day and
they too probably caught people up in
the energy so just one final comment i
would
urge anybody that criticized me for
entering an eyewitness account of the
record
last week to please read the eyewitness
account
to take a look at actually what the
truth is thank you
thank you before i call on senator
merkley i just want to ask you
miss amber one thing uh these people uh
that were
um assaulting the capital um uh win
military gear
and were pinning an officer between a
door
and were using bear spray
on officers in the capitol would you
title them
provocateurs
ma'am it would all depend on the
evidence behind the case right so as
we're going through and we're figuring
out what actually we know about each
individual it would just depend on what
the facts
and what we know holistically about that
to be able to put a label on it do you
think there were some very
serious violent people involved in this
insurrection
100 a lot of officers were injured and a
lot of damage was done
and would you describe the atmosphere as
festive absolutely not
thank you uh senator merkley
ah thank you madam chair and thank you
to all for your for your information
uh assistant secretary salesis
if i understood your earlier comment you
thought the quick
reaction team was only for
reinforcing assistance to those members
of the national guard
providing traffic control did i hear
your comment correctly
yes senator you did uh thank thank you
major general walker i i believe
that if i heard your comments correctly
that quick reaction team was there to
respond as needed including protection
of the capitalists
is that correct no senator so they were
actually
to provide support to the guardsmen out
there
what i would have wanted to do was
remission them
and get them to the capitol immediately
as a quick reaction force
i see so they weren't necessarily
planned to help protect
the capital but you would re-assign them
to that
in that type of emergency yes sir
okay uh thank you that clarification
uh i was really struck by the complexity
of the chain of command
for trying to get a decision for
response
it starts with the capitol police board
which goes to the chief of the capitol
police stephen sun
who goes to the commanding general of
the d.c
national guard who goes to the secretary
of army
who then consults with with people
within department of army about whether
it's appropriate which then goes to
secretary of defense who then consults
christopher miller to decide to study
that
who then gives an order back to the
commanding general of the dc national
guard uh
this six-step
process seems totally
unsuited to the situation of responding
quickly to
an emergency and just wanted to ask you
commander walker uh if if i'm reading
this
chain of command correctly and if if do
you share the view that this is
way too complex for a moment when you
need to respond
quickly so senator it's a long-standing
process but it it can work
in minutes so for example
during the first week of june the
secretary of the army was with me
i watched him call the secretary of
defense and consult with the attorney
general and respond back to me with
a approval within minutes
so so it's an elaborate process uh
but it doesn't always have to be when
in extremis circumstances we can get it
done over the phone what if very very
quickly if i understand right it's
normally an elaborate process done in
advance and in fact the
information came to you on january 1st
you got back a response on january 5th
so this was before
january 6 but it had this provision
that this restriction that i think
you've testified to
was unusual that required reconsultation
on january 6 in a fashion that deeply
inhibited the ability to move quickly
that's right senator
okay uh thank thank you i wanted to uh
turn uh to uh
under secretary smith slovakia
and you've been with the department for
for how long
17 years sir for 17 years and i think
you were
the deputy under secretary on january 6
is that correct
yes sir okay well i was uh
struck by different reports that came
from
officials saying that there was a a mood
within the department
and i'll just quote one formal official
reports
quote nobody wanted to write a formal
intelligence report about this
in part of the fear that such a report
would be very poorly received
by the maga folks within dhs
and to follow this up brian murphy
former head of dhs
i don't know were you also the deputy to
him as well i was one of his deputies
yes sir
uh he noted that dhs officials had
ordered him to stay away
from the threat of white nationalism
that chadwood
ken cuccinelli also had asked him to
modify
intel assessments to ensure that they
matched up with public comments by
president trump to downplay
downplay the threat posed by white
supremacists
in your time at dhs
it's very important that intelligence is
unaffected
by politics it's like the root
information
did you get a sense that there was kind
of a troubling
cloud as reported in various sources
including
from the the former head of dhs that
there was this troubling cloud of
political influence over the quality or
the
kind of determination of how
intelligence was prevented
presented to to officials
um i can say that ina's reports
did not change we did not change our
assessments based on any
political pressure or interference we
did
publish the homeland threat assessment
it's a publicly available document
that does state that white supremacists
are the most persistent
and legal threat and lethal threat to
the homeland
so did you ever feel any pressure or
receive any
uh encouragement even kind of in a
lesson
formal way i'm not talking about a
written document that you needed to be
very careful about
clarifying the threat posed by white
extremists i did not personally receive
that
and do you consider brian murphy's
report that that type of pressure was
applied to be accurate or inaccurate
um he has uh his is a whistleblower
complaint and it is still being
judicated
no i understand but i'm asking you you
were right there in the the leadership
you never got a sense that there was any
type of political influence like he
reported
uh regarding uh encouragement to
downplay
i did not personally have that influence
pushed upon me sir
okay thank you someone suggested that
the reason that there were formal
intelligence assessments regarding
earlier events including the protests in
portland but not
such a detailed presentation
related to january 6 was because of this
pressure to downplay to some degree the
threat posed by white extremists
i would like to point out sir that the
two instances are very different
our support during some of the civil
unrest and the prose
test specifically in portland where the
direct request
of our own dhs federal law enforcement
partners
and in that capacity we were reacting
to a pattern of violence that had shown
itself for
several weeks our open source team did
an excellent job
in many instances of providing specific
information that kept those officers
safe they were reporting things like
bricks may be used today as a weapon
another day it might be bug spray
combined with leaf blowers or lasers
our work um by contrast
leading up to the election and january 6
is quite different it's a different kind
of an environment there's not that
pattern
violence it is a different kind of
assessment
so i do suggest or that it's it's
impossible to compare the two
uh thank you for your your testimony
thank you thank you madam chair
mr chair
thank you senator the chair recognizes
uh senator
cinema for your questions oh thank you
um mr chair and thank you to our
witnesses for being here today
during last week's hearing we heard
about coordinated security planning
efforts between law enforcement
and federal partners for january 6
including areas
where planning could be improved as part
of this conversation the committee's
heard about
intelligence shared by the fbi field
office in norfolk virginia
on january 5th warning of extremists
preparing to travel for quote
war we also heard from the former chief
of u.s capitol police that he never saw
this report
and that on january 6 he knew of no
intelligence
suggesting there would be a coordinated
violent attack on the u.s capitol
the head of the fbi's washington field
office has previously said publicly that
the bureau did not have intelligence
suggesting the rally would turn violent
prior to the january 5th report
however on january 8th a podcast from
the new york times
outlined activity across multiple social
media platforms
showing coordination between groups
ahead of the january 6th attack
the podcast highlighted social media
conversations about coordinating travel
bringing weapons and using language like
occupy the capital
and the revolution will come to
washington so my first question is from
miss sanborn
was the fbi aware of these specific
conversations on social media
to my knowledge no ma'am and i would
just sort of articulate why that is
so under our authorities because being
mindful of the first amendment and our
dual-headed mission
to uh uphold the constitution we cannot
collect first amendment
protected activities without sort of the
next step which is the intent and so
we'd have to have an already predicated
investigation that
allowed us access to those comms and or
a lead or a tip or a report from a
community citizen
or a fellow law enforcement partner for
us to gather that information
so the fbi does not monitor publicly
available social media conversations
correct ma'am it's not within our
authorities
so my next question is for miss sanborn
and then ms lislova
did the preparations for january 6th
rally follow the typical process for
sharing information among law
enforcement entities
when confronted by this type of an event
with a high potential for violence and
were there additional processes
implemented
to consider that as senator klobuchar
pointed out this was an event with
congress in session
and the vice president and vice
president-elect all gathered in one
place
yes ma'am so a couple of things we did
different than normal operations
is we sent out and made this a national
priority for
all of our 56 field offices to actively
go out and ask sources
collect information on any threats that
posed
to the national capital region not only
for the six but for the inauguration
that tasking is what led to the
potential collection
in the norfolk field office we also a
step we took that is
different than our normal every course a
day of business is both washington field
office
and headquarters stood up command post
so we activated our nc3
which is a multi-agency task force that
was 24 7
inside the hoover building inside sayak
in washington field
mirrored that in their field office
and ma'am yes yes ma'am
and dhs also ina had been
on a heightened period of alert after
before the election and then after the
election
we also participated in the command
posts
in the washington field
the washington fusion center in
retrospect we
may have been better off if we had
considered sending out some kind of a
terrorism bulletin but we did not do
that
before january 6.
so in this default question for both of
you the fbi field offices did have
intelligence outlining a threat to
congress
we know that conversations were
happening on publicly available social
media
and dhs was tracking the travel of some
of these suspected radicals
so given all of these pieces what in
your opinion broke down and what got in
the way of law enforcement properly
planning
to meet these publicly
articulated threats
i'll start uh i think
exactly the processes we had in place we
followed and i think that's the good
news i think
as you heard the director yesterday and
i would echo anytime there's an attack
we in the fbi want to bat 1000 and we
want to not ever have this happen again
and so we're asking ourselves exactly
the questions that you're asking is
there a place that we could have
collected
more is there something that we could
have done and so
that is exactly what we're looking back
at i think that the information we had
we worked quickly to try to get that
out in reporting and share it in
multiple ways
verbally email putting it in portals
etcetera but 100 percent you can rest
assured we're asking ourselves
the same as we want to continue to
improve and get better
and ma'am we also at dhs are completely
dissatisfied with
the result of our efforts leading up to
january 6.
we are re-examining how we distribute
our information
how we coordinate with our partners we
thought that it was sufficient and
clearly it was not
we are also working much more focused
on uh applying more resources to better
understanding this particular threat
we also are looking at how we can better
understand social media
to get those tips and maybe get better
insight
into what this adversary is doing this
is a very difficult
threat for us and the intelligence
community to understand
it is um will require more partnerships
with
non-traditional partners and with our
standard state and local partners
and you will see that we will reinforce
our already good partnership with the
fbi
we will do better thank you
following up on on that last comment
around local partnerships
um i wanted to go back to miss sanborn
on january 5th the fbi did receive
information
that armed protests were being planned
at capitol buildings in all 50 state
capitals
could you just briefly in the time we
have left share how that intel was acted
upon and how it was shared across the
country
man i don't recall off the top of my
head i'd have to get back to you on the
mechanism that we did to share that
information
so with based on that response would it
be fair to assume that it was
not a particularly high priority um
that there were armed protests planned
at all 50 state capitals across the
country
no it 100 was a high priority and it
definitely
for our mission and our focus we were
not on the sixth only focused on the
national capital region we were focused
on the whole country and so it 100
was a very important focus for us i just
can't remember the mechanism of the
document or whether it was an email
whether it was a joint product
how we passed that information but we
were concerned with it and i know we
disseminated it in some form and i owe
you that
thank you so i'll just have my team
follow up with you uh mr
chair i see that my time is expired i
yield back and thank you
thank you senator padilla you are
recognized for your questions
thank you mr chair uh
let me first a comment then a question
for
the witnesses uh i understand
you know there's a lot of people saying
they'd like to see a reconstruction
of the events of january 6th and how
they came to be
for anybody genuinely interested i
turned their attention to the
house impeachment manager's presentation
to the united states senate from
february 9th through the
13th our questions today though
are in some ways a follow-up to
yesterday's judiciary committee hearing
where we heard from fbi director chris
wray
and i'm going to quote from his
testimony yesterday quote
we are not aware of any widespread
evidence of voter fraud
much less that would have that would
have affected the outcome
in the presidential election end quote
and yet former president trump and other
people with influence
continue to spread lies and
disinformation
about how the november 2020 election was
stolen former president trump continued
this
effort most recently at the conservative
political action conference
on sunday falsely claiming and i'll
quote from him
we did even better in the second
election that we did in the first
you know i won the first we won the
second we did much better
prior to joining the united states
senate i served for six years
as california secretary of state which
includes the responsibility of serving
as california's chief elections
officer for the most populous state in
the nation
i know trump is lying
we all know trump is lying
fbi director ray told us yesterday that
one of the biggest
challenges the government faces in
confronting domestic terrorism
is separating the signal from the noise
this was particularly true in the
lead-up to the january
sixth insurrection when people of
influence
particularly former and current elected
officials
continue to spread lies and
disinformation
about election integrity i would imagine
that creates a lot more noise
unnecessary noise counterproductive
noise dangerous noise
for you all to have to sift through
i suspect it also serves to radicalize
some number of people to actually take
action
including violent action just as we have
seen
for years with jihadist propaganda
and other forms of foreign terrorism
so my question for each of you two
questions actually one
does the perpetuation of disinformation
about the 2020 election
make your job harder and how
second what kind of message does
the january 6 insurrection send
to other domestic violent
extremists and
our foreign adversaries as well
i'll start i think i'd start with
pinpointing the specific uh
thing that just drives somebody to
mobilization is very very very difficult
and it's probably more complex in the
domestic violent extremist space than
any other
of the terrorism threats we face and why
that is is what we've found in our
investigations
is domestic violent extremists not only
are potentially doing what they're doing
in an insular manner
but it's a combination of an ideology
that they have and what makes it
different
is a very unique personalized grievance
and when those things combine that
appears to be
what pushes them to mobilization and so
for every single individual we're trying
to find that
but it's incredibly hard and it relies a
lot on their ability
you know post-disruption to explain that
process to that
and so that's something we're trying
very hard to get to the bottom of on
each of these cases
and sir we um we did more in our
national terrorism advisory system
bulletin
that we assess perceived grievances that
are
fueled by false narratives could
continue to mobilize
or incite people to commit violence so
to that extent yes false narratives are
difficult
or difficult
senator the department of defense does
not do domestic intelligence on
u.s citizens but there's no tolerance
for extremists
in the ranks of the defense department
secretary austin within the first few
weeks
of taking over as a secretary order to
stand down
in the defense department a one-day
stand down to examine extremism
educate people and make sure that we're
doing everything we can to root that out
senator i'll spot you for a second
because i want to make sure
i get some clarity here now i know these
issues are complex your work is
tremendously
complex and challenging but the answer
to the first question
based on what i hear tell me if you
disagree is
the question being does this make your
job harder the answer would be so far
yes yes yes is that correct
it's twofold right it's volume any more
volume makes it harder
and the more variety of things that
inspire people
definitely makes pinpointing it to a
specific one challenging and so variety
of inspiration
combined with amount of rhetoric out
there
definitely are two things that add okay
and the limited time i have left i want
to make sure we address the second
question which is
you know what message do you believe
this is sending to other
domestic violent extremists let alone
foreign adversaries
we do uh we do assess that the uh
breach on the capitol could inspire
others to act if that's what you're
asking sir
i agree anytime an adversary is
successful others pay attention and so
we're worried that this would be an
inspiration
i agree with that i agree as well sir
thank you thank you venture
thank you uh senator just uh for for
planning purposes before
i recognize the the next member from my
committee our witnesses you've been uh
here a long time uh so what uh our plan
is to give you a little
in the future here in the near future a
chance to stretch a little bit
i'm going to recognize one more senator
from my committee chairwoman of
klobuchar will recognize one from her
committee then we'll give up give you a
five
minute break so with that uh senator
rosen
you are recognized for your questions uh
thank you chairman peters i appreciate
you and uh all the other senators on the
rules committee for bringing together
this joint hearing is really
important and appreciate everyone for
being here
you know uh in october 2020 dhs warned
uh that and i quote racially and
ethically motivated
violent extremists specifically white
supremacist extremists will remain the
most persistent and lethal
threat in the homeland unquote and that
quote again
violent actors might target events
related to the post-election
period unquote according to a former dhs
assistant secretary for
counter-terrorism and threat prevention
the office of intelligence and analysis
or ina was aware of the potential for
violence on january 6
and i quote again but for reasons of
fear didn't want to formalize
reports we know senator merkley asked
you this question already
but in fact the day before the attacks
ina sent a national summary to law
enforcement partners stating that there
was
nothing significant to report nothing
significant
to report and so if dhs assessed white
supremacists
to be the most lethal threat to
americans and if ina was aware of
domestic violent extremists mobilizing
to cause violence on january 6 then why
didn't the department
issue a formal intelligence warning that
violence could occur and i'm asked
this of miss uh
yes yes ma'am um first
we have heard of that report that we
sent
supposedly sent out that said nothing
significant to report and we cannot
locate that
so i have no uh idea where that notion
came from walk with us on that report
see if you can find it or
where we get we've we've looked ma'am
for for a while
um so we do we don't we don't have a
copy of that report this wouldn't be an
official report ina sent out
it is possible ma'am that what it came
from was maybe a phone call
or something else where we said we had
nothing additional to report
we did view the work that we had done
prior to january 6 as being sufficiently
specific in warning of the possible
threat
some of the reports we did distribute
you
uh just quoted from yourself so it was
our belief that those warnings were
enough
obviously they were not we are working
very hard now to do two things
one get better specificity and insight
into this particular threat
and then secondly understand better
how our customers receive our products
read our products who gets our products
it is unclear to us why um
they were not received and we were not
better prepared
for possible things i'll follow up on
that did i
a share any intelligence products with
national fusion centers relaying
information about possible
violence on january 6 and is capital
police
part of the dc area fusion center
yes we talked specifically to the
capitol police
in early december made sure that they
were in receipt of all of our products
and they received again the one
we put out just a week before the attack
that we co-authored
with fbi national counterterrorism
center
we know that all of our products do go
to the national network of fusion
centers
and we in fact participated in a phone
call
that was sponsored by the national
network of fusion centers
the day before on january 5th where we
also reiterated our concerns
that we were in a heightened threat
environment that this particular
adversary
could mobilize quickly and they most
likely have small cells
lone offenders they would most likely
come
armed and they could were interested
in attacking specifically government
buildings and large gatherings
well i appreciate that but it seems like
we weren't exactly ready so uh
moving forward i know you alluded that
you're going to try to figure out where
your product goes
and who talks about it but how are you
going to specifically elevate ina's
assessment
at white supremacists are the homeland's
most thankful threat so that
quality detailed and informed
intelligence
actually reaches our communities
including our local law enforcement
ahead
a possible attack so that we can prevent
any loss of life certainly or
other kinds of damage yes ma'am and the
department
is committed to doing that our secretary
is very committed to coming up with a
whole of dhs approach to
better combat domestic terrorism we are
working
across the department to understand how
to better articulate the threat
and deliver the threat and how to
mitigate it with our
state and local partners thank you
i want to move on because the day before
the insurrection the fbi
issued an internal warning that
extremists planned to take part in
violence on january 6.
last week i asked metro pd about the
intelligence failures
leading up to the attack acting chief of
police conte told me that fbi
emailed mpd and alert bulletin warning
about potential violence at 7 00 pm the
night before the attack
mr conti told me again i'm going to
quote here i would certainly think that
something as violent as an insurrection
at the capitol
but weren't a phone call or something
unfold
but yesterday fbi director ray shared
that his information had been provided
to local law enforcement
multiple times and in multiple
forms so miss sanborn it sounds like
either
uh mr conti or director ray was a
mistaken so can you corroborate director
gray's statement
and if indeed the warning was only set
in writing why didn't the fbi
go a little bit further i why did not
alert local law enforcement about the
possible
violent insurrection in a manner more
consistent with the gravity
of the threat yes ma'am i appreciate the
question i think i'll start with
the information we received just to
correctly characterize what it was
was information off the internet
unattributable to a specific person
that being said the content and the
suggestion of what
may or may not happen was concerning
enough that based on our prioritizing
this is a collection priority for our 56
field offices
they quickly wrote that up and within
the hour had that information to the
washington field office they wrote it up
in a document specifically for
dissemination to state and local
partners
but really they tried to belt and
suspender that together they wanted to
make sure
that we just didn't rely on the
dissemination of a product
that we also followed up with an email
so it went out in an email to all task
force officers on the washington jttf
task force
and there's numerous of those from the
national capital region that received
that email
still on top of that they didn't want to
rely on just the email and the written
document
in one of the command post briefings
that they were doing back then every
couple of hours
they specifically stood up and talked
about this to try to have a common
operating
picture of what this information was
and then still to go a step further and
not rely on just that and make sure that
we broadened the visibility
not just to the national capital region
but we opened that aperture to the whole
country for our state and local partners
we posted that
situation information report on what we
call the leap portal
which is available to all state and
local partners and why that's
significant
it gives them awareness but it also
gives them the opportunity
to maybe even potentially add collection
to what our piece that we got from
the social media posting online thank
you i know my time's expired so i'll
take this question offline but uh
you're encountering so many online
threatening uh posts
we need to maybe change the definition
of thanksgiving let's
raise them up thank you very good
thoughts senator rosa next senator
warner from the rules committee
thank you madam chairman and let me also
uh agree with
you and and senator rosen
that the cross colonization that takes
place
on social media platforms and on the
dark web
need to be pursued i appreciate ms
sanborn's
appropriate response that cannot
arbitrarily
collect off of american citizens
if there's not some nexus but i do think
it's important
i think others have mentioned this that
you know domestic violence extremists
didn't start with january 6 they didn't
start with donald trump they're not
going to end with january 6 we're not
going to end with donald trump
um in my state we saw a few years back
the united the right
rally at charlottesville where many of
these same
groups and affiliations came together
and another
violent effort where
one protester was killed and
fortunately lost a couple members of our
state police
director ray has repeatedly said
in testimony before the intelligence
committee
the worldwide threat assessment that
domestic violent extremists
uh are a major national security theme
i personally believe that that message
was downplayed during the previous
administration because they didn't want
to hear it
and um when i i want to
start with miss uh slova and
assistant director sanborn director sam
warren it's great to see you again
is that recognizing the constraints
that uh are placed upon you in terms of
collections
uh and also acknowledging that this
threat has been around for some time
the fbi in particular has acknowledged
that it is
an extraordinary major severe threat
what have you both been able to do in
engaging in
open source intelligence
and independent research communities to
better identify
these ddes i know in the run-up to the
january 6 in selection
there was research done by harvard john
donovan and eon university's
megan squire as well as other uh
researchers that pointed to the fact
that these ddes and the affiliated
groups oftentimes groups that are
in working in junction with groups in
europe um
we're planning this effort so how are
you
both dhs and fbi utilizing
these independent researchers uh open
source activities
and and making sure we've got a better
handle on it recognizing your
appropriate constraints on what you can
do directly
yes senator thank you for the question
uh we
just last week met as a as inside ina to
discuss
contracting with some of those experts
outside
we are aware that we need to invest more
in our understanding of domestic terror
we understand as well that it will
require a different approach
than a traditional intelligence
community approach we must use
different sources to understand this
threat
we are looking to get outside experts
invest more
in house we are secondly looking at how
to better understand
the social media world so that we can
better focus on where we might
actually find specific and insightful
information
about what the adversary is thinking
about we are additionally
working to partner more with our state
and local colleagues who
we know have a different perspective of
this threat and have more
information in some cases than we do and
we are also
again partnering more across the
department
and with our federal partners um
increasing our relationships with fbi
thank you senator nice to see you again
as well it's try to say what we're
trying to do and i'll put it in three
buckets really for
you increasing our private sector
outreach is 100
i have a section just inside my division
that does nothing but
partner engagement we have found that
the better we educate them on the threat
we're facing
and painting a picture for them of what
those threats we are they're better
able to pay attention and collect and
refer information to us and that is
helpful and i think that's why
when we talk about the fact that 50 of
our tips and leads to our cases or
predication for our cases come from that
relationship and that education
we're also same as a my colleague said
using the state and local partners so
we leverage the fusion centers a lot in
their ability and their expertise
and the orange county fusion center in
california is a great example of
leading sort of the analytics of social
media and leveraging their expertise to
predicate cases and they were actually
behind the predication of the case the
base that we disrupted
and then last i would say challenging
ourselves for better collection
inside right trying to point our sources
and our collection
to be in the right places to collect the
intelligence that we need
and that is what led to the norfolk sir
that is
us pointing our collection in a space
that gathered that information
i have to tell you respectfully i'm i'm
pretty disappointed with both of your
answers um
this is not a new threat we've seen
since 2016 election
how foreign adversaries manipulate
social media
hear repeatedly from dhs and fbi that
we're going to get better
at collecting uh we saw the unite the
right rally in charlottesville
we heard people say we're gonna get
better
at uh collecting information and
better partnering uh neither one of you
referenced
um there's literally a host of
experts at academia and organizations
like graphica
and others that are monitoring the dvds
and their activities oftentimes in their
connections to
anti-government groups in europe again
oftentimes amplified
nations like russia and i i just you
know we're always going to get ready and
then we're
somehow surprised when we see the kind
of
chaos that took place on january 6th we
can't always be for saying we're going
to do better next time
when this threat has been around for
years
it is not going to disappear with donald
trump there's never been somebody that
was as active in
encouraging these kind of individuals
but we got to pick up our game and i do
think
the academic researchers are a tool that
we need to
better develop i think we need to work
uh
it was from the intel side with some of
our our forum partners because
many of these groups have connections to
to foreign
anti-government extremists and i'll just
close i know my time is going out i had
does not directly retract for sanborn
but i had a number of senior
conversations with
fbi officials both january 5th and
january 6th where i was constantly
reassured
don't worry we think from the fbi
standpoint we've got this
pretty well under control that was not
the case and
we now have the capital of the united
states desecrated
and for our adversaries i think from an
intel standpoint the vladimir putin's
and the xi jinpings of the world the
images of those marauders
across the whole world is going to be a
price that will be paying for many years
to come
thank you madam chair um
thank you very much sarah warner and
thank you for your work as chair of the
intelligence committee
uh we're now going to break five to ten
minutes um so
uh we will be back at that moment thank
you
we'll come back to order
senator langford you are
recognized for your questions mr
chairman thank you very much for this
but it says thank you uh i appreciate
your engagement uh we're trying to all
fill in blanks
and uh none of you have all the answers
on this we're not expecting this panel
to be able to cover everything on it but
i do appreciate
the gaps that you're helping us fill uh
as we go through this conversation
together
miss uh sprislova i want to ask you a
couple of questions about the ic
i've read through some of the sensitive
information that was sent out to law
enforcement in advance
of january the 6th help me understand
someone that's getting that report
obviously many of these folks that are
getting the report from capitol police
and others
sergeant-at-arms they get reports like
this similar every day
if i look at the j the reports prior to
january the six that are coming out from
intelligence
i have a hard time looking at it and
getting the context of how is this
different
than normal so help me understand for
those reports
for someone who's reading these reports
every day
how would they understand the context of
what you're seeing or what the
folks are seeing on the ground that's
different than what they had seen three
months before six months before a year
before
yes sir that is um that is a great
question
and that is one that we are now
reassessing
it was our view again when i prepared
for this hearing and i looked at all
of the work that we had done
specifically
talking about the extremists that would
be motivated
by the dissatisfaction with the election
results
and also unhappy with some of the
restrictions related to kovid 19
the the reports are quite good they are
well written they seem to
summarize pretty succinctly i mean i
look at them and i'm proud of the team
which has produced twice as many reports
on domestic terrorism this last year as
they did the year before
but to your point it might be hard to
see
that trend over time in um in the noise
so looking backwards from you know now
what didn't happen
right we are examining should there be
different types of
um reports should we use some of the
tools that dhs has such as
the national terrorism advisory system
we have restarted
the counterterrorism advisory board
which was
uh occurring monthly under the previous
administration and had fallen off for a
variety of reasons
the last few years we've restarted that
secretary mayorkas is challenging us all
to do a better job when it comes to
combating terrorism domestic terrorism
so i guess that's a long way sir of
saying we are taking a look at our
the reports that we have done we will be
engaging
very directly with all of our
stakeholders asking them what we could
do better
asking them how they might better
receive the information
should we put in a different format is
there some way we should remind them
that this is an alert and it is hard
candidly with the volume of information
that we all receive
daily sure you're getting tremendous
amount and that information continues to
be able to flow but when i look at the
reports
and look at even the bottom line up
front that's at the beginning of it it
all seems very standard to me
there doesn't seem to be an elevator
risk now there's some details that come
afterwards
that if you're reading through it you
could then elevate it and then
as you've heard some members on this
committee and others in the media have
pulled out specific statements buried in
a report and pulled it out and said well
how could you have missed this
right but in the bottom line up front it
looks very standard
uh here are the ear the wrists here the
things that were that we're seeing uh
there doesn't seem to be something that
would say hey this
is higher than normal if if i can use
the intel term it seems to be chatter
even in the report itself it identifies
multiple places this was one person on a
social media site and they had one
comment
that they made on it